qui se disent on sait que pas de nous
depuis le début je vous ai demandé de ne
augmentation qui ne cesse de croître
pense que c'est ce qu'ils voudraient les
années que vous êtes en direct vous du
fait vous parlera dans une seconde alors
législatives on le sait sont très
bonjour mesdames et messieurs bon
poste débat comment vous avez vous
savez elle avait donné une conférence de
monsieur stéphane besson qui a milité
contraire m'aurait fait de la peine si
dessus c'est un président centriste et
macron soit soit passée d'un autre côté
emmanuel macron qui change de mars
persévérance et l'affection que vous me
après demain bien sûr mais c'est aussi
donc on ne tourne pas comme ça le dos à
madame le pen commence son discours tout
enthousiasme en scandant des marines
des couples homosexuels et puis les
paris lui déroule le tapis rouge à celui
de faire la politique après emmanuel
lui a dit non pas ça pas ça mais c'est
dernière fois dans son discours après le
jamais je poursuivrai mon engagement
largement placé en tête du second tour
évidemment entre les deux propositions
possible cain qui ternit est confiant
il s'est fait qu'il est allé quand même
présumer en effet que si tout se passe
recevoir comme ceux de la planète des
km est heureux ce soir de voir que ont
majorité ce qui se ressemble sans doute
outre ans dans l'agressivité dans la
l'assassinât de l'enseignant samuel
étonnant qu'elle reste mais peu importe
résultats oui oui l'a payé cash pour
et 19 juin ont lieu les élections
trouve lors de son discours intersil
en position d'infériorité ici au québec
elle a mis les étrangers les immigrés en
puis le temps sera important de noter
priorités dans les sondages d'opinion
sais que pour nombre de nos compatriotes
deux mouvements qui vont tenter de
dit sur votre plateau le plus difficile
qui se rappelle michel ses origines a
dans le discours qui s'apprête à
autre fracture sociale qui se déclarent
notre parti reconquête efforts de ses
qui avec une sincérité intacte ne
même jupiter s'était installé ce soir là
qu'eric zemmour but se présenter aux
a on n'a pas eu beaucoup d'électeurs ici
c'est vrai que c'est quand même un sujet
notamment sur ces enjeux qui sont liées
le pen et les gens sifflent et dean
que des échos via des calicots ça ne
connaissez m
qu'on sait que marion maréchal qui
personnelle indéniable vous l'avez dit
ne peut y avoir de victoire électorale
l'autre cas où
qu'on va voir la participation qui est
fait me lasson mardaille là ce qu'ils
aurait transmission donc du salon où il
veux remercier l'ensemble des militants
esthétiques qu'est-ce qu'on peut encore
depuis depuis trois jours comment
marine le pen qui dans la défaite
vous donne moins de mackenzie - de
on avait un petit peu vécu ça avec
finance justin trudeau qui à son tour
ligne infinie là ça s'est mieux passé je
au titre de président de l'union
voix d'avancé sur sur marine le pen et à
politiques et même qu'à la fin quand la
que marine le pen essayait de se
presse à d'entre deux tours convoquer
évidemment frappant vous parlez à votre
90 pour ça avait voté à peu près pour ma
amis
allez mes enfants
mais en tout cas il fera pas de
à l'issue de cette séquence
désespérés de monsieur mâcon pour aller
soit soit en tête au second tour mais là
on peut dire que sa carrière payet sait
peut-être peut-être pont de l'europe à
propose d'écouter quelques heures ses
macron ce n'est pas la première fois
dimanche le verdict dans une heure et
mais être dans la foule je pense que on
lançant des françaises les français
c'est pas une surprise tout gâcher
pour le parti d'eric zemmour reconquête
français français pareil pour ce qui est
prononcer sur les champs de mars ça
a été très clair c'est vrai le soir du
que jupiter a changé j'ai compris
résultat emmanuel macron qui est réélu
aussi ça peut être important on peut
devrait cette unité par laquelle seuls
jamais sifflé parce
premier tour et qu'il fallait réinventer
à l'heure en disant jamais nos idées de
qui est à la tête des socialistes donc
quand même assez compliqué mais en tout
même hélène chez le soc enfin c'est
marié ne chaque fois qu'elle parlait
qui suscite une véritable haine une
ce mouvement-là va-t-il prendre la place
alors s'il a fait
vont être très minces pour monsieur
bien à peu près une demi heure que parce
vers ce qu'on pensait être un barrage à
pâtit donc on a voulu aller en réaction
le seul chiffre pour l'instant dont on
compatriotes ont fait le choix du corps
avec force pour les années qui viennent
pour la france et les français la
législatives pour ce qui est de
années
voix marine le pen n'est pas très
aussi mais allait être bienveillant et
sur une possible refonte des
entendu par le président sortant donc en
voulaient même temps il doit tenir
nicolas sarkozy
tout le monde pour marine le pen pour
cadres partout en france fort de ses
législatives
analysé ce débat est l'effet de ce débat
entre les deux tours s'est fait
qui se sentent délaissés la tort ou à
d'abord de réduire les inégalités d'une
important on se rend compte que les
à montréal mais
également de 10h30 à 15h30 de 10 heures
s'appelait marion maréchal-le pen à
siffle et page 9 ans
européenne c'est une place qu'occupe la
comme les sondages de 10 ça se passait
dit aussi a fait 7 % au premier tour
qu'elle avait essayé quand même
banquier marine le pen a rétorqué
consolé de l'europe avec cette élection
perdre le troisième tour en étant trop
commence la vie politique française est
dans cette mondialisation c'est quand
canadien avait mis non pas qu'il n'ait
petit peu à l'image d'emmanuel mâcon
effectivement la question est de savoir
chercher déjà à gauche pour apparaître
empêcher on enlevait ont connu un peu ce
élire par les français avec un gros 50
s'imposer à l'extrême droite et à la
sa vie parce qu'on a encore perdu et
célèbre le big 3 et 6 8 ans semble
priorités électorales des français c'est
c'est très rare pour un président de la
lui est encore en campagne pour les
particulièrement à nos compatriotes des
totalement libre
qu'il parle de faire la politique
forces c'est possible c'est
distancier de eric zemmour durant le
compte assurément de ce résultat qui
ouais je pense que manuel macron bah
que c'est dont on savait qu'elle
c'est une tout autre question mais on
macron va arriver et rld écrivez nous un
félicite emmanuel macron jade de
dynamique était davantage de son côté
électeurs plus traditionnel des manuels
cas pour pouvoir être d'avoir une forte
d'une etc lenteur de victoires en trop
suivre envoyer les images en direct
l'état de polarisation débat public en
très exactement 35 % des voix les études
60 % des voix ou entre les deux comme le
beaucoup élise intéressant alors
cohabitation avec un un gouvernement ici
pose aucun cas
notre heure donc ça va aller at iront
dispose officiellement 17 heures heure
122 mille adhérents et je remercie ceux
peut-être qu'il peut dire ça
sans alliance entre toutes les droites
transigerons pas avec vos intérêts par
devant la tour eiffel livre coller à ses
recours à des firmes privées peut-être
des panneaux solaires donc plus
demie très exactement nous serons si
rester elle veut mener ce combat là pour
national et du changement
engueuler
on n'est pas très loin de la fête là on
non mais c'est pour ça que je vous parle
l'assemblée nationale il faut la sauver
raphaël vous y vivez en france vous là
qu'il y avait des sondages qui sortait
pavillon d'armenonville dans le 16e
famille qui décide donc mais la famille
vous pouvez battre monsieur matheron et
chers compatriotes
je tiens à féliciter manuel macron pour
présidentielle une grande recomposition
ceux qui ont eu le courage de s'opposer
que les services publics doivent être
qui ont choisi aujourd'hui l'extrême
c'est pas la politique de thé c'est une
en étant dépositaires aussi
personnes âgées et les retraités
et des patriotes pour que les élus de
éventuellement venir rejoindre le camp
point les électeurs de la droite
différemment il avait en 2010 est créé
effectivement les gens retrouvent toutes
fois que la défaite frappe le nom de le
l'époque a laissé tomber le pen s'était
ce sont ici ou si haut c'est vrai à 40,2
n'avez pas ménager vos efforts avait
aussi
je pense que c'est important d'aller
avoir des velléités de remporter les
emmanuel macron et ce barrage n'a pas eu
là au lieu de travail de travailler à
cette conférence de presse là pour
jean luc mélenchon c'est d'une certaine
symbolique de la montée de cette extrême
gouverner il plafonne au quand même des
une responsabilité
france jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle pas c'est moi
pour atteindre le second tour il faut
taxés quand même beaucoup d'arrogance on
comme mission de réunir un pays qui est
lever sur le pays le sort des urnes que
parce que je pouvais pas
haine viscérale chez certains français
l'interdît donc c'est vrai qu'il va il
raison mais ils se sentent délaissés et
qui au premier puis au 2e tour m'ont
croix montréal 88 je croise des normes
viennent leur adresser la parole bien
un champ de ruines les deux partis
confiant au deuxième on peut alors il
au deuxième tour oui le front
pas si mal en fait macron est apparu
qu'elle était une femme totalement libre
même un score honorable raphaël une
achevait de toute façon elle même dit
voit clairement qu auprès d'une partie
part d'autre part de réduire les sept
législatives
il a voulu quand même être rassembleur
institutions en france pourquoi lorsque
m'honore et me touche sincèrement cette
va s'employer à envoyer ses messages là
écouter juste au moment là deux d'entre
macro il ya tout ce mélange ici de gens
parce que le problème le problème du
gauche du spectre politique on entendu
talents de sa créativité de ses
tout affaibli et les sondages de sortie
manor majorité minorité au parlement est
arrivé quelques positions évidemment
par rappelant que des millions de
remonter le gonflé à bloc pour la place
les électeurs français plus en plus ça a
pas apporté évidemment ses condoléances
dès à présent
comme problème c'est qu'il y à beaucoup
indique une des bases du front national
dans cette campagne marine le pen a dit
candidate est la candidate de l'extrême
salariés par des commerçants par des
comme quelqu'un qui se soucie lui aussi
que ça vient pas que de lui mais mathieu
il ya des petits groupes qui se sont
va régler le problème pense pas que ça
indispensable
sa réélection à titre de président de la
mesdames et messieurs c'est dans moins
difficultés des vies vécues et de
des républicains où les républicains
débat-là ici mais je sais effectivement
débat est ce que pour vous ça a été le
on se prépare on réchauffe la foule avec
que nombre de nos compatriotes ont voté
de lily caucase il peut battre justement
façon qui parfois eu du mal à cacher son
puis quand elle parle de deux scores
c'est pas pas tout à fait terminée quand
demain à partir de 14 heures on a tous
on parlait de coalition semaine
d'éoliennes plus de solaire elle veut
aussi à tous nos compatriotes qui se
à emmanuel macron second tour bref avec
absolument pas je mènerai le prochain
déjà distancié de s'attendre donc c'est
poursuivre notre travail ensemble sur
mitterrand et jacques chirac qui s'était
second tour alors qu'il lui avait servi
qu'il parlait et avec le président de
effet la façon dont il va dès l'automne
de la population ça ne fonctionne pas et
et parmi ces gens ce qui est une source
regards sont tournés vers les élections
populaire les électeurs de nicolas
certainement pas aussi flamboyant qui
faire son devoir citoyen ne me semble
une bonne probabilité que ce soit ça oui
monsieur macron va réussir à se faire
regroupement familial c'est à dire ce
sûr après 8 heures probablement après
millions d'électeurs votent pour moi
maison ressemble beaucoup d'électeurs
donné tant d'énergie partagé tant de
sur l'électorat
son propre mouvement politique qui ne se
chacun d'entre nous aura à s'y engager
conséquent nous lançons ce soir la
peu la scène que vous avez à côté de
c'est notre devoir bâtissons au plus
droite en france donc il ya énormément
ça c'est une réalité politique
républicain des électeurs a fonctionné
traditionnels parti socialiste les
respectueux car notre pays est pétri de
france et relever les défis qui nous
reconquête du rassemblement national de
droite la colère et les désaccords qui
qu'elle ne voyait pas l'utilité de
derrière les enjeux liés à l'économie il
français dit elle ont choisi le camp des
que c'est sa dernière campagne je pense
pris de l'ampleur avec les impacts de la
mais oui c'est vrai qu'elle est liée à
l'alu défaire son piédestal oui comme
supporters son premier discours comme
si c'est une fille c'est un combat
ont semblé parfaitement incompréhensible
alors
madame le pen monsieur mélenchon qui
laissent entendre certains sondages on
choses au tarif abonné au site ni pour
pourraient resurgir on ne sait pas trop
oui on peut pas dire s'il ya eu plus ou
et son soutien la france mais on avait
sondages font leur travail il va finir à
ne règle le problème mais il faut
coalition et ce qu'on appelait la gauche
ce qui est vrai aussi c'est que marine
des votes au premier tour faut-il le
par contre elle aussi misé beaucoup sur
droite bien qu'elle ait tenté d'adoucir
de crise exceptionnelle aussi
va être dans l'action moi je le connais
si on veut limiter sa à l'islam il s'est
le jargon un coût des télévisions donc à
de femmes aujourd'hui en france qui
donnerait déjà un peu d'aidé là pour les
lieu donc marine le pen qui devait faire
image où il se montrait début je dirais
pense que vous n'avez pas de réponse le
de son côté peine légaux ici qui
je respecte en a voulu autrement en
de paratonnerre durant le premier tour
pour ça on le dit tout à l'heure jamais
gens qui ont dit que nous avait menti
l'on verra dans l'est j'espère sûr mais
lescure ré inventer des modes de
république française ga de poursuivre le
emmanuel macron l'a abordé et il a dit
distances qui séparent les trois grands
même parce qu'il n'a pas le choix mais
également d'outre-mer dimanche qui ment
les enjeux importants pour les canadiens
qui continuent de nous rejoindre chaque
compétences nous serons donc à la pointe
des divisions qui se sont exprimés et
gratitude à tous ceux qui m'ont fait
au cours des prochaines semaines parce
à l'hôpital pour l'ensemble des
choisir un autre chemin
est-ce qu'on n'a pas le sentiment que je
présidentiable crédible sur des sujets
incontournable qu'est-ce qui la macro
france
de la halle à suivre essayer de
circonscriptions donc ces gens là et il
il a dit dès l'automne prochain
en présence bien sûr deux ministres
pas garanti il va voir la réconciliation
demain
voter régulièrement quand les jeunes
répondre avec efficacité aux colère qui
d'inquiétude c'est qu'il ya énormément
montréalais en courbit déjà voulait dire
point final des biens qu'il faut être
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils aient intérêt
bros plusieurs réactions ont peu partout
ce jour pour moi non pour soutenir les
pas forcément d'accord avec avec tous
nouveau combat de demain avec un
des compagnons de rouge et lui qui
l'immigration est un dossier qui ne
vous leur
pendant cet entre deux tours il a voulu
de ce qu'il appelle le droit national on
d'attention alors si sa victoire est
sérieuses dans les échantillons ben
leur est espérée dont il s'y attendait
républicains ont fait ensemble 6% au 1er
voulait ni de droite ni de gauche et on
joints à lui il espère faire élire
plurielle tient que les socialistes ont
sont abstenus
grande bataille électorale des
toucher tués après coup c'est fascinant
50 à 55 8 points 8 mais ça vous donne
tous ceux qui ont la nation chevillée au
précisément qu'on aura les résultats à
entendre cette cette colère sociale
y ait la guerre en ukraine plus
conviction
la russie qu'elle est liée à des
d'après les sondages n'y a pas eu
guerre en ukraine en jeu qui s'est aussi
pas qu'il y en ait une autre impasse
patriotes elle remercie particulièrement
senti une vraie différence de vision
admiration
8h30 et peut-être 9 heures quand on aura
combat at-elle dit pour les législatives
bourgeoisie patriotes entre les grands
l'unss qui est avec vladimir poutine
les français de la défense de la
par rapport à 2017 et par rapport au
le to va débouler le résultat bien sûr
il est arrivé dans une atmosphère assez
appliquant même qu' il ya d'autres
pas seulement marine le pen de
qu'on a traité beaucoup d'arguments et
va attendre en tout cas dans le discours
rappeler et je me trouve avec l'un des
tente de sortir de ces élections avec
une fois de plus et je pense qu'il doit
son image est d'ailleurs emmanuel macron
même dans ses patins peut les dire même
fonctionnaires un cumul de dispositifs
deux bouts la france et ceux des
blocs de l enfant le bop le pen le bloc
et partout à travers le territoire en
barrage à manier emmanuel macron qui
c'est un remarquable qui entre les deux
réélire pour une deuxième fois ce que
de jean-marie le pen d'abord avec le
l'un ni pour l'autre et encore une fois
après une période de cohabitation
prendre soin et l'eczéma ou encore sa
que je le répète c'est pas bouclé il
cette france cran publiés nous nous ne
encore une fois bon alors ce n'était pas
législatives mais comme elle le disait
à trop en faire alors bon là le décor
nicolas sarkozy sur ceux là dessus enfin
ne se passe pas nécessairement comme il
marine soient venus d'une catastrophe à
circulait on sentait que donc elle est
moins d'électeurs que le 10 avril
en 2002 il fait 18% des voix là elle a
récemment mais quand même c'est toujours
attendent
on n'a pas eu de n'a pas eu de grand
toutes ces histoires avec monsieur
assez emmanuel macron pour pour savoir
leurs proches chez eux elle veut mettre
je voyais cette défaite venir depuis des
raisonnée partout sur le site ici on
deux jours avant la fin de la campagne
carmen il faut souligner une chose
réelle pour les français mais d'autres
accordé leur confiance afin de faire
leur silence a signifié un refus de
quand on voit que beaucoup d'électeurs
portent effectivement un foulard on peut
convaincre sur ce qu'ils appellent les
fonctionnement être plus rassembleur ça
dominant et l'affirmation face aux
leur tendre la main maintenant est ce
tensions sociales il doit reconnaître
en tout cas pour moi très clair non mais
mais vous savez ici il ya un mélange de
a vu qu'au bout de cinq ans il ya quand
président réélu
parce que je rappelle aux gens qui nous
s'envolera pas non plus puis compter sur
gouverné aussi avec les communistes et
c'était escompté cette victoire comme
dj way alors rassemblement et bombay on
temps de doute le temps de divisions
président vainqueur et bien vainqueur
jour il est fort de ces milliers de
certainement mais l'acte doit composer
d'effet majeur du débat sur sur les
sent quand même que les couteaux sont
importants il faut le dire les membres
c'est celle effectivement dont a
qui fonctionne gérard araud sans ce
des électeurs de montréal et du canada
le front national est autrefois bien sûr
peu près 28 de trente caméras
voila merci annick du côté de madame le
se sont exprimées
allée à hauteur et bien il va vouloir
partis dont elle parlait de
dépit de deux semaines de méthodes
appelé à voter pour madame le pen le
pour représenter cette force que veut
ok je n'ai pas entendu non on n'a pas en
réformes pour moderniser la france
à jamais
les années à venir à coup sûr
y en a quand même un certain nombre ces
bien souvent utilise le terme front
les ont conduits à voter pour ce projet
vous voyez on va rappeler quand même
très important législatives sont plus
donnait les sondages lui donnaient 40 2%
beaucoup de gens de la gauche et devenir
les résultats et qu'on aura entendu pour
républicains qui ne veulent pas se
surveiller l'ampleur de la victoire de
l'association des gagne petit et puis
ceci dit la france et lui s'est voulu un
contre toutes les
travail que nous avons entamé je suis
pour moi est devenu l'extrême centre
corps le rassemblement national oeuvres
parents et leurs petits enfants entre la
dans ces inquiétudes qu'ont une partie
nièce marion maréchal qui a rejoint est
du combat pour lutter pied à pied contre
quand même avoir un non seulement un mot
en fait qui se rapproche de la loi 21
les français qui ont voté pour elle dans
reste les législatives le combat
madame le pen qui parlent en premier et
une bonne performance au premier tour
que concrètement il posera des gestes
démocratie à la lutte aux changements
c'est en frappant au coeur que vient la
tours il est allé dans les terres de
des différences et en veillant chaque
le moment de dire il y aura tel projet
père aimé mais même avec elle bien sûr
le prévoyait monsieur bah dis donc il ya
un peu moins arrogant que ce qui lui a
beaucoup plus grande chez les jeunes
sortis parce que prédire une marine le
dernier lors du premier tour mais une
advenir notre projet pour une france
nous sommes le
si le mercure 7% son parti a beaucoup de
emmanuel macron est le premier et le
l'effritement mais vous savez le parti
même énormément de frustration en france
volonté de laver l'affront subi en 2017
bénéficié
accepté l'offre du gouvernement et je
écoutent que c'est un match revanche
lafleur donc c'est les bonnes nouvelles
premier tour très bien oui on va y
est quand même grandiose la tour eiffel
tour au premier tour de scrutin
s'intéresse à parce que comme aux états
somme toute plus de président français
depuis le début ma compagne et ont rendu
les dix quinze prochaines années une
une idée de dans les petites
c'est la première réaction d'importance
d'émission pour dettes publiques peut on
et on verra si leur à l'humilité de
avait l'envié voire au moment où les
idées que je porte mais pour faire
faire faire barrage à certains candidats
rétablir les comptes publics rembourser
c'est très bon ce que vous êtes gérard
du cabinet actuel du gouvernement qui
le président de toutes et tous et je
à attirer ce vote là et bien c'est jean
mon avis total donc la partie de
mes chers compatriotes mes chers amis
déloyales brutale et violente
patriotes que ce soit de gauche ou de
fin à ça du côté des manuels macron il
monsieur lescure le disait depuis de
espace qui était circonscrit derrière
élites autoproclamées d'emmanuel macron
zemmour et le pen pour en parler
sur ces images explosion de joie
rapprochement possible stratégique entre
veut dire quoi
rallier à emmanuel macron est une chance
recul un peu là pendant qu'on voit sa
jean luc mélenchon lors du premier tour
les écologistes donc il ya eu une
cela
pour monsieur mélenchon bonne
44 il avait été élu le plus jeune à 39
festive assez détendu il a passé
septennat et ça c'est quelque chose qui
macron la république en marche par non
incontournable dans la formation du
sur les marchés un peu financier
doit on va voir pour les retraites etc
puisque vous l'avez dit 58% à peu près
sentiments c'est à dire une déception
des défis évidemment qui vont au delà du
climatiques à la croissance économique
officielle
et jeté au canada c'est emmanuel macron
des républicains et même certaines
fiches la somme de droits de la personne
non pas contre le séparatisme donc elle
les français comprenaient on va baisser
alors je suis une expression que
des gens qui doivent avoir un revenu
retraite sera un marqueur effectivement
fier de la relation que le québec a avec
madame le pen a quand même le pen est de
il a voilà il n'a jamais eu besoin chez
doivent aussi trouver une réponse ce
national plutôt qu rassemblement
il ya un certain nombre de féministes en
mort au long de la campagne faire partie
gens là vont aussi pâtir du rejet dont a
hexagone dans nos outre mer comme à
marine le pen de se voir présidente ce
choisir
le champ de mars il est au coeur de
possiblement les autres discours
assez c'est un autre disque mais
pour la fin de semaine prochaine et pour
résultats il ya des estimations qui
électeurs que le reste de la population
luc mélenchon c'est d'être allé chercher
faire la semaine des as si c'est
42 43 c'est à dire c'est quand même une
france périphérique et les habitants des
mais aujourd'hui on a à peu près 28 %
beaucoup d'électeurs ici avec quelques
pour madame le pen c'était les deux
les campagnes dans les provinces mais
alors comment va-t-il faire ça il ne l'a
encore possible si vous élisez une
araud et j'en profite pour vous
démontrer qu'il est toujours aux
pour eux mais aussi peut-être leur beau
unis comme au canada aussi dans une
l'oublions pas
ici au québec sur la laïcité de l'état
lorsqu'il devait commenter le fait
voir marine le pen pour les législatives
chez nous ici au québec c'est le premier
été reprochée dans ses premières années
monsieur macro sea gagne pas mais là
rares à unir tous ceux d'où qu'il vienne
beaucoup la wii il lui doit je boxe
pour madame le pen qui avait fait la
pen le nom de le pen ça fait huit fois
moteur de ce dialogue qui n'a pas montré
c'est un rassemblement donc il filme et
parce que bien des militants et la
municipalités dans les endroits plus
alors il nous faudra être fort
vous dirai en ce moment le juge juillet
l'oeuvre de déconstruction de notre pays
que en tout cas les deux à trois
seconds les remerciements vont tout
politique se poursuit mais on le voit
jour au respect de chacun et en
législatives à devenir extrêmement
c'est vrai et je trouve qu'il a il a
que non mais la dernière fois en 2017
plus indépendante une europe plus forte
il ya un dossier qui pourrait raviver
de la population française d'où le fait
seul à ce jour président à se faire
l'homme les hollandais applaudir donc un
résultats ouais les résultats ont été
du courant national comme véritable
voiture qui arrive près du champ de mars
vérité
troisième au premier tour nous espérons
non je demandais comment vous sentez
elle renonçait pas la victoire mais déjà
les taxes ça ça va bien moi j'ai fait un
n'est pas anodin puisque vous savez que
bien pendant qu'on le voit faire son
ya quand même quelques propositions qui
monsieur je faisais départ à la clé avec
auquel nous nous devrons aussi de
ont réussi à faire il ya mitterrand et
plus fluides donc elle a eu de longues
lui même
sont là mais on sent pas une si grande
barrage à celle de l'extrême droite
et c'est vrai que même dans l'hypothèse
peut amener à la législative seront
vingtaine de réacteurs de nouvelle
gaulle aucun président n'avait réussi
beaucoup ne comprennent pas mais je
rester dans ces terres justement il faut
france comme ici je crois certaines
un petit peu de d'occulter pendant le
gouvernement et donc c'est pour ceux qui
tentative quand même de gouvernement a
veut s'attaquer précisément à l'extrême
d'autres chefs politiques dont celui de
de peser voire de dominer dans la
cette élection possible je sais que vous
et monsieur macron qui parle en deuxième
similaires à celles que subissent au
des gens qui ne votait pas on a parlé de
déterminée nous ne sommes plus que
dont il ya pas de grande surprise en
c'est quand même un très beau score
féliciter et l'on change de sujet de ce
l'otan et la russie après la guerre et
l'étranger
de son éventuelle équipe gouvernementale
moi vous avez le champ de mars est un
partout il ya nuit la liberté de
suffisant pour remplir le panier
qui t'es arrivé premier au premier tour
commandes et puis que la foule et les
quand elle avait subi un véritable
fois à tout le monde même si on
avait été quand même plutôt dominant sur
premières années de son mandat vont être
merci et je sais ce que je vous dois
qu'il appelle directement à voter macro
pour la classe moyenne il ya aussi la
au centre bell vous voyez ici il y a des
paris de l'histoire de paris etc donc
importante parce qu'on se rend compte
soit ce que ça a été un moment décevant
politique de son adversaire tout ça ces
mais en 2004 par exemple cette loi-là a
ans à l'époque des plus jeunes du g20 il
une progression effectivement très
donner quelques quelques intention de
d'électeurs donc pour l'instant vous
oui mais michel monsieur legault qui
c'est ce qui fait
on voit aussi un taux d'abstention
message qui est envoyé
justement de se positionner comme
prononcé les mots qu'il fallait respect
vous à quelques minutes avant le
métropoles qu'ils veulent continuer de
on est passé à des mandats de cinq ans
l'émotion
effectivement que marine le pen se
pas aborder concrètement et de grandes
sera ma responsabilité et celle de ceux
ministre françois legault qui dans dans
pour vraiment peser et le diabète le
petits c'est pas une super g marie pour
bien finir premier au troisième tour
rebelle parce qu'on s'attend à ce que
aujourd'hui
naufrage elle avait envie de finalement
vous très présent chez nous et notamment
aussi dans les outre-mer et elle dit
aller dans les endroits qui lui étaient
emmanuel macron en lui donnant 40 2% 1
la france et de l'amitié qui unit nos
candidate ou si reproche une campagne
deuxième fois par le peuple français
qu'il nous fait perdre bon ben on se dit
quelles sont d'après vous ces qualités
gaieté de coeur que je l'annonçais j'ai
sous toutes ses coutures on me dit que
elle avait eu beaucoup moins
autre mesure il ya deux il ya souvent
faut que chaque français y portent
souhaitait gagner au deuxième tour pour
d'épicerie comme il le dit donc ça il va
dit on peut encore infléchir
c'est un beau score oui il reste qu'ils
qu'il ya plus une leçon de son premier
que macron est élu très bien donc on a
génération
majorité je dis bien une majorité de
bouclier fiscal qui permet de m
entrée au chant de marge
débat est intéressant de suivre le débat
pâti quand même emmanuel macron au moins
et à gauche et élargir le sens bain
peut-être pas le même alors 50 jours
les états unis tram qui aussi se disait
le 3 mai à la cathédrale marie reine du
des années où on va pas chômer comme on
mais elles seront historiques et
répondre
mais nul ne sera laissé au bord du
troisième fois que la famille le pen ne
alors comment on va réussir à mettre
une grande efficacité pour l'instant
habituellement c'est quand même assez
grand votre livre sur quel schengen est
où emmanuel macron gagnerait ce soir que
nouveau mandat il ya ce soir oui faut
files d'attentes on se rappel lors du
quotidien les français les idées que
des françaises et des français qui n'ont
marie dont 26 tous parce que décrivent
j'aime que vous me parler
cette jeunesse qui ne votait pas des
premier ministre du futur président de
important dans les quartiers
assez rapidement certaines tensions et
quelques minutes après les résultats du
calculs évidemment c'est pour rappeler
chaque fois je vous en avais parlé la
jamais et notre volonté de défendre les
hostiles vous avez raison après il y
on sentait qu'elle avait peut-être
pense que ce qui a gagné aujourd'hui
et par des investissements et des
on sait que edf en ce moment a du mal à
menés par emmanuel macron nous
madame le pen vient de s'adresser à ses
partage la vision française la laïcité
voter des jeunes voter des jeunes des
dévoilement du résultat
mais on parle beaucoup de l'abstention
espace très vaste on n'aurait pas pu
le rassemblement national nos idées at
plusieurs mais ce n'est pas une
devant de la tour eiffel mathieu
affichés sur le tableau donc à la minute
rendez vous manqué
pour les présidents depuis 2002 et là
l'atmosphère de 2017 alors qu'il était
prochaine assemblée
avec une majorité de suite là se faire
mandat c'est une petite phrase que faire
ce tweet félicitée mme hanoune affront
oui on le voit arriver j'entends
contre-pouvoir pourquoi protéger les
dernière fois tu de comparaison 33% et
fébrilité je dirais même si bon la
des différences pas vote d'adhésion pour
moment là c'était en 2014 ça fait trois
a 44 ans aujourd'hui ce mandat dit il ne
madame le pen et là on va essayer d'y
europe mais une victoire de m le pen
au niveau le député qu'est ce qu'on a vu
idées une reconnaissance d'abord que une
on le sait durant le débat le président
vivre dans une france français
trahison ce qu'est l'esprit français
d'environnement raphaël
électeurs ont fait qu'ils sont présents
périphériques les banlieues des grandes
1er tour des gens ont attendu jusqu'à 3
vraiment prisonnière de son programme
depuis des décennies en politique on
classe moyenne a même moins entendus
gouverner autrement on a beaucoup
été renforcée pourquoi parce qu'on a
moi je suis pas sûr mais je suis pas sa
importante et puis elle ne peut pas s'en
dans le dialogue avec la dernière pause
dit non et vous alors comment vous allez
aux français quel est le choix qui est
j'ajouterais aussi pour être pour être
compris qu il lui en manque réel à
pas voté c'est historique donc il faut
par ailleurs je sais pas où il ya eu des
et moi la scène à il va arriver je fais
on en fait on savait que on était assez
quartiers populaires qui ne votait plus
vous l'avez dit bête le contre-pouvoir
hargneuse à emmanuel macron mais en même
premier tour donc à mon avis c'était le
il a fait cinq ans il va refaire cinq
peut-être que c'est même plus efficace
condition comme comme en allemagne ou
dire qu'il ya des réalités économiques
pendant cinq ans les électeurs de gauche
monsieur macro non il ya des endroits il
c'est l'arrogance le mépris est ce qu'on
continuant de vrai à une société plus
il a il est très jeune encore on le
de parler avec les électeurs après ce
pen c'était écrit michel raison c'est
qui m'entourent car le vol de ce jour
aussi il veut elle limiter l'octroi dé
jusqu'au premier tour donc c'est pas
avait aussi c'était aussi un moyen de
2500 si je ne suis je me souviens bien
c'est très long en politique alors c'est
militants dans vers 20h30 et je les
des voix donc il ya quand même plusieurs
cette campagne d'entre deux tours ce
que pour la coalition veut ça va quand
je me sens serein parce que c'est aussi
départ j'avais prévu de partir hier et
qui ont fait parce que malgré tout avec
c'est un dossier qui est très important
de de weeds de laver son honneur elle a
que emmanuel macron comme le disait
monde ici sur rené lévesque merci
mais sinon très difficile de se faire
regarder les forces à la droite de la
devoir tenir compte de son sans aucun
oui c'est un rendez vous manqué pour
nations mais justement c'est une bonne
là dans cette élection en 2022 le taux
villes et ça ça pose toutes sortes de
nous représentons arrive à des sommets
merci je le scier
je crois que rappelle en parler sur la
deux sociétés
aurait craché sur toute une secousse en
changements profonds continuer d'assurer
et ceux venus
il est voilà ah ouais ration non marine
français contre l'insécurité entre
sortant emmanuel macron a profité de la
confiance pour présider notre république
d'énormes dommages cantier dire je
mais ça lui a été relativement peu
à lire ça se lit merveilleusement bien
ensemble nous aurons à les écrire pour
français est encore renforcée je n'ai
climat davantage je veux en faire plus
fait ce que j'ai pu pour éviter ce
ici la plus fortement
moi je suis des baux dépositaire de tout
quartiers notamment et c'est une
frustration à l'endroit de la direction
même si la loi québécoise ne va pas
reproché à emmanuel macron et moi je
politiques et des lectorats mais c'est
humaniste ambitieux pour l'indépendance
la future présidente il a du bon
un autre d'autres qui disent non c'est
pour sa réélection il à avoir hâte de
devant le lancement voilà le voile est
ans que marine le pen est à la tête du
ensemble tous ces gens là bas c'est pas
yannick un hectare dont avait fait un
ferveur vous l'entendez remonter parce
l'éléphant dans la pièce et la guerre en
débat là aussi parce qu'on a parlé
comme un commanditaire chacun 1 puis là
le champion des perdants de la
chemin alors il nous reviendra un simple
d'abstention est un sujet d' analyse en
que la france connaît des fractures
que les technocrates lui en dix ans mais
en construire un à peu près tous les
interdit les signes religieux
emmanuel macron tenter justement de
heures ici au palais des congrès à
maximum qu'ils pouvaient faire en faveur
imaginer utiliser tout cet espace parce
constitution française contient la
leurs forces contre la politique d'
cette force singulière
mathieu lui aussi fait des propositions
ils proposeraient peut-être un septennat
combattrons pour nos idées dans chaque
à la présidentielle nous sommes
mais vous pouvez pas faire ça en moi
en effet auront lieu les élections
j'entends l'hymne à la joie qui avait
un bloc républicain qui marchent parfait
semaines d'ici les législatives mais
vraiment exhaustif que le parti du
qui avait abandonné le parti communiste
députés de la nouvelle union populaire
vous inscrire dans ce mouvement monsieur
lors du dernier budget à ottawa mais qui
mathieu macron 66 alors oui elle a grugé
ce mouvement est arrivé d'à peu près
elle dit dès le début ne se sont jamais
même être un petit peu compliqué il
va suivre ça je rappelle mesdames et
c'est encore prévu par les sondages et
on a reporté le départ à ce matin
ans sauf si évidemment il y à une
redonner le goût aux françaises et aux
doute je me doute mois qu'il va avoir
communicante donc je n'ai rien à lui
élire mathieu prost c'est un fait la
c'est pas gagné complètement s'est pas
l'ont vu s'éloigner d'eux et se
du grabuge et ciela ce qui est pas non
questions sur l'intérêt qu'ont les gens
une chaise derrière cette proposition là
reproché d'ailleurs par par ses
est son avenir politique est elle oui
travaux d'hercule ce qui attend le
il est il est perçu comme état du côté
temps on respecte le résultat des urnes
juste et l égalité entre les femmes et
sur le pouvoir d'achat sur la crainte du
ya des endroits et comme on dit raphaël
colère pouvait ressentir en verre à
un vêtement de soumission donc on peut
écrit dans le ciel
marine le pen mais c'est pas forcément
s'est branché donc sur nos collègues de
élire une deuxième fois est ce que
ostentatoires et on parlait
trouve que parfois c'est un leitmotiv
soulignait tout à l'heure mais ses
il veut s'occuper de thèmes qui touchent
titres de séjour pour les étrangers les
l'humaniser et de montrer effectivement
oui électeurs français inscrits au
parlé sur le coup le cahier une annonce
effondrés donc c'est pas gagné pour
finalement la question de savoir qui
autres contre un quinquennat qu'elle
qu'a pris le pays du moins car une
ça donc ça c'était vraiment important je
poursuivre le travail entamé et fier de
l'emmerdé les non vaccinés ça lui
droite de la sphère politique venez nous
emmanuel macron afin de présenter ou de
un soir de second tour de l'élection
première et je trouve que c'est plutôt
aussi loin que la loi française mais
vrai que ses revenus en seconde partie
entendais et ce corps des marines mari
les remercier
de l'âge de la retraites un dossier dont
l'aboutissement de plusieurs mois de
pour l'instant pas question pour marine
question ce tour de table là dessus quel
ukraine où si oui oui c'était même plus
que le nouvel imac mon arrivée des
front national à ce moment là et pour
mondialisation et la carte électorale
sera pas le prolongement de mon premier
montréal cette fois ci on a changé plus
que faut un petit peu fatiguant son
mouvement en marche et que les gens le
déclaration universelle des droits de
législatives
revient défense de la classe moyenne
aujourd'hui aucun ressentiment ni
la colère d'une bonne partie des
maintenant qu'elle est vraie l'avouerez
les progrès concrets pour chacun en
très bien alors vous allez avec nous
rien et il a réussi beaucoup de choses
qui sont liées au dossier de
président elle en marche en réalité n'a
allemagne parce que quoi qu'elle en dise
frappes à elle car en déclin après son
là que ça s'est joué je trouve que le
certains étaient partis au rassemblement
bon reportage radio il ya trois semaines
bataille pour les législatives ce qu'on
a appelé le en même temps et
à la fin les électeurs ne comprenait pas
je pense enfin à ceux qui ont voté pour
c'est un peu ce qui lui dit
une génération
bien le plus dur restait à faire et
président macron 2 alors ce soir il va
de notre pays pour notre or un projet
qu'il n'y avait pas cinq ans des
commençait pas et vous avez raison et
c'est possible c'est réel c'est 20 c il
convaincre des électeurs qui ne sont pas
opposants personne ne l'a rendu
proposer mais je pense que une arrivée
rapprocher davantage de la droite là on
par hélicoptère il va arriver au
et on se console en voyant le score
qui doit s'élargir
c'est c'est assez secondaire et moi j'ai
l'occasion de faire des choses plus haut
france beaucoup plus important que chez
une
gerbes de fleurs les gerbes de fleurs
crée un nouveau quinquennat et
titres longue durée à ceux qui par
elle est encore
partie de l'électorat pas tous mais une
france 2 et qui vont nous donner les
complètement acquis ce soir qu'emmanuel
on envoie 2002 c'est là évidemment ça
qu'il n'était pas ce président arrogant
ville et dans chaque village de france
j'aurai l'occasion de vous en reparler
français d'aller à la politique pour
beaucoup de gens pour faire le vote
présidentielle
si je faisais un peu mentir des sondages
autant il faut que l plus de convaincre
elle est largement inspiré de ce qui se
campagne sur le terrain ici avec le
pense pour essayer de renouer le fil de
emmanuel macron moi j'ai été voir
retombe sur le nez à chaque étape de sa
l'homme de 89 et s'attaquer à une
l'immigration ce n'est pas un sujet non
les élections de 2015 elles contractent
plus anormale dans la vie politique
canada 67000 quand même à montréal donc
lendemain et des paniers difficile
sujet quand nous parler de
aussi les retraités d'ailleurs en france
et leur dire que j'ai conscience que ce
c'est ça qui touche la vie quotidienne
la relation québec france justin trudeau
le pen de baisser les bras elle est déjà
de dire pas une voix pour renaître le
de marie et tout de suite après vous
ici à un tel niveau elle a quarante deux
l'idée de ne pas rééditer ça la 4e
voir ce qui avec zéro hora dire
les jeunes également oui mais vous avez
métallos qui peut-être arrivé en fait
arrogance se sont mépris mais sauf que
accompagné d'ailleurs son sa première
du vote oui elle est plus forte venant
national ces gens là ont voté mais
coup
pour pour marine le pen appuyer de façon
personnes qui allaient venir assister à
fête on n'avait pas ça oui c'était des
français envers emmanuel macron à
le sentiment qu'il va réussir mais qu'il
qui vivent dedans soit dans ces
on entend beaucoup parler encore hier je
candidate dans cinq ans elle avait dit a
cinq ans pour autant elle a laissé
que le son sans sa solution était était
c'est plus ça fait encore davantage
et puis quand l'avez devant elle encore
la configuration de l'accueil de
appelle ici le troisième tour des
est c'était dans les faire renoncer à
proportion des personnes qui ont voté
d'emmanuel mâcon elle crête qui sera
rejoindre même chose pour mélenchon à la
temps politique est trop court en cinq
américaine le montre bien des régions
avait été très très serré elle redonne
soutenir des candidats partout et donc
maintenant et il aurait à partir de ce
avec plus de 43% des voix le résultat de
champ-de-mars il va tout en blanc comme
pourraient lui manquer on attend encore
l'élégance par assommer madame le pen en
trouvé qu'en terme de mobilisation
du tout favorables à sa candidature on
souhait
une bonne nouvelle ça veut dire que ce
sur internet et dans les médias mais il
qu'un éléphant dans la pièce au moment
libérant la créativité l'innovation dans
partie des français alors que va-t-il
des gens particulièrement l'europe à
plus que le président peut ignorer voilà
fait en france oui effectivement est
malgré tout
nous par exemple or dans les pays du g7
parce qu'il n'est pas mort il ya 90 ans
défiler jong avait encore pas mal sur le
les hommes
également at elle besoin de lui il n 'y
que moi roland lescure que doit faire
l'international de l'ukraine pour
week-end précédent a été beaucoup plus
utile à mon avis c'est à dire que ils
la veine certaine fébrilité une certaine
quinquennat mais je veux et tenez vous
historique de madame le pen jamais
que certains dénoncent et oui qu'il
emmanuel macron c'est on va de tous les
française on a utilisé des gaz on est
moment là dans les établissements
irréaliste du nucléaire qui arrive dame
saint fons dans les résultats mais je
a bien vu dans les dernières semaines
des gagnants par beaucoup de gens qui se
j'ai sur la scène politique pour tenter
qui s'accumulent depuis vendredi et
c'est le cauchemar de la gauche puisque
vous voyez peut-être mieux que moi mais
concrétiser ce statut passez moi
qui illustrait à quel point le thème de
campagne cette fois ci alors je pense
idéologie n'est pas possible les
voilà ça c'est un appel patrice qu'on a
sur un pied de guerre sourds elle s'est
jamais réussi à s'implanter
après son autre quinquennat il aura il
des gens plus à droite dans ses
mac ont remporté haut la main une
comptable est coupable on l'a plutôt
14h00 alors voilà mathieu je disais est
du débat mercredi soir parce que
été attirés par le mouvement des coteaux
élections elle dit qu'elle va poursuivre
enterré nous l'avons été mille fois et
le bloc populaire qui s'est constituée
effectivement ce voile ce serait en fait
en direct que son arrivée kabylie le
un prêt auprès d'une banque russe qui
le verdict final ici où je me trouvais
pour mac roues contre la proportion qui
ce discours de manuel da cruz alors on
au mieux si on fait des comparaisons
pas s il est pas très loin du 60%
victoire il ya cinq ans symbole européen
steppes à deux quinquennats mais quand
mélenchon pour le premier tour vous avez
parti de la majorité la république en
ce pays complètement fracturée on attend
donc là dessus c'est très clair qu'on a
a un petit peu plus tard des mets a
résultats en direct on voit des images
est dans le réel mais en tout cas on a
plusieurs égards que ce soit par rapport
vote mobilisent pour les années à venir
moment là une responsabilité historique
savez quand c'est apparu les résultats à
gauche de la gauche du spectre politique
l'a suivi le lendemain du premier tour
sous le signe du mépris très intéressant
allez que vous êtes au rassemblement de
madame le pen dont je sais la déception
le fameux triangle qui est moins
nouvelle vedette de la politique bon on
dans votre circonscription en métropole
pense qu'il faut aussi changer de
pen en insistant bien sur le fait que ce
c'est le même phénomène en france ses
l'europe que des diagonales de peine
plus humbles un discours encore une fois
soir dans son allocution pour laisser
intensément et que je suis si fier de
elle est une nécessité
coeur le fait que bon il y avait ému de
plus eu un passage pour rester mais elle
surtout l'ordre du tour des efforts
semaines pardonnez moi on disait jamais
le 21 avril lionel jospin a échoué à se
est parce qu il ya un côté théâtral bon
républicain dans ses valeurs
honorable plus que ce que lui
ans mais il ajusterait le calendrier
c'était la déception on a parlé à un
priori non mais en france tant qu'on
rappeler les liens financiers entre le
d'enseignement pour le primaire et
nervosité
raison de noter la la mise en images de
chef sujet qui peut ignorer macro non
disant ce nom là sera jamais à coller
partie de l'adn de l'ancien front du
quand vous entendez on a entendu
bien
nous impose d'agir les élections
majorité présidentielle alors s'il n'a
sentent laissés pour compte dans la
elle avait un petit peu quand même mis
enfin voilà avec la vraie punchline
faire sur la question des retraites sur
à montréal oui on voit les chiffres ya
en cinq ans le parti du président la
donc c'est à dire je les passerai un
juristes disent que des condamnations
pour cent je vous le rappelle ce qui est
n'y suis pas parvenu en appelant sans
méthode associer directement les
avec le mode de scrutin législatif qui
côtés on est à droite on est à gauche on
va réussir pln on a parlé monsieur
qu'il a appris ça on peut voir on peut
était capable d'aller rencontrer les
son engagement elle dit aussi que vous
partenaires de la rejoindre il nous
meilleure que celle de madame le pen est
atteint par le pen depuis que la famille
vont faire barrage un rassemblement
entendues dans l'entre-deux-tours
publié cette photo de dos avec emmanuel
notre pays et pour faire de la france
investir dans une nouvelle méthode
référendum sur l'avenir de l'europe que
mars mais aussi les membres du modem qui
aujourd'hui il y à partit donc plusieurs
conversations de gens qui nous parlait
est circonscrit la zone derrière voyant
n'était pas envisageable de voter pour
elle se serait retirée de plusieurs des
marine le pen est toujours là les gens
a
second tour a priori qu'au premier tour
il veut associer ça a des compétences
l'écran il ya eu des huées mais il y
la france c'est là où l'on vote le plus
c'est celle de se dire et si dans cinq
week-end pascal avec donc des jours
toute comparaison est boiteuse mais
très rapide ou s'il a utilisé les gaz
ont voulu faire un barrage république
évidemment emmanuel macron ne cache pas
trop l a jamais osé attaquer emmanuel
emmanuel macron à appuyer
mille fois l'histoire a donné tort à
à sa politique sociale que ce soit aussi
non non non non willis vous êtes là avec
qui viennent n'a vraiment j'ai donné
et dans le contexte de l'ukraine de lire
démocratique et on faisait des
même il se faire élire et c'est
elle est un devoir nous avons un pays à
raison ça fait pas une majorité et la
déjà lancé dans la bataille oui voilà
entendre qu'il est un rassembleur et
d'actualité mais québec paris ottawa
s'appelle la first cheikh rachid banques
bien que et années qu'il faisait
la question de l'environnement sur la
décrit comme étant plutôt centriste d'
en outre-mer et dans les
profite mais c'était ce que la famille
l'environnement n'a pas été du tout
qualifier pour le second tour c'est jean
c'est là où la théorie pour faire
prédisaient les sondages il y a encore
regardé l'expérience française doit
sous le boisseau cette partie là sauf
féliciter de même marine le pen
pas de majorité dans cette veine
de ce soir non le sifflet de personnes
deuxième tour voyez dans son cas on est
salue pour l'instant il ya six députés
supérieur aux 34 % qu'il avait eu la
français qui étaient en opposition avec
compter là dessus alors voilà il va
parti de madame le pen en laissant entre
françaises et les français via ce qu'on
débuts le même phénomène et monsieur
imaginez monsieur macron dans sa voiture
présidentiels c'était fini on est dans
électoral en mettant des midterm salles
clairement sur des terres où c'est
n'est pas mort on n'est pas mort en
de l'âge de la retraite donc c'est très
barbier vous en avez parlé aussi il va
ancien reconnaissance et sony ou tard
mondialisation on va faire oui tout à
militant qui venait de lille qui disait
quelques électeurs là tout à l'heure
cette arrivée parce qu'elle n'a plus
va c'est quelqu'un d'autre que le pen
je suis dépositaire
côté théâtral de toute façon peu importe
elle bon ce qui est intéressant c'est
ça déborde feu de ce qui avait été prévu
justement ce fameux programme web simon
elle arrive sur un compatriote
pas du tout et il va falloir voir aussi
nous ont rejoints deux territoires de
national c'est pas les premières ça fait
maintenant emmanuel macron dans la
même doublement est inconstitutionnelle
comme on dit en bon français
parallèles avec bernie sanders la
fériés à lundi férié trois jours que les
savez on voit jamais abandonné
un projet social et écologique un projet
je comprends que les gens qui se sont
électorale pour montréal seulement ces
majorité aujourd'hui ou est ce qu'elle
visiblement un problème de relation avec
rend même pas il leur a même pas ça
trajet aussi est filmé ça c'est les
traités est essentielle de l'aude alors
question du pouvoir d'achat tout ça
aux défaites et ça fait 8 fois il faut
marie le pen qui est là et la victoire
cinq ans demande à mel a aujourd'hui on
alors on verra on me donnera des détails
une grande nation écologique je sais
d'ailleurs pendant le débat voilà à
emmanuel macron donc ça se fait dans les
personnes également qu'ils viennent
tout ce que je pouvais pour pour avoir
nouveau rassemblement mathieu proche
madame le pen qui déjà ya deux jours
république est allé de défaite en
absolument pas de retrait dans son cas
ostensiblement sur ce bouton en lui
circonscriptions de l'étranger je vous
finalement passera vous et ils n'y
renforce les tendances politiques et on
qu'il veut aussi tenir compte des
effectivement assez notable relativement
aussi des masques on l'a vu l'an dernier
servir à nouveau vibrer il n'est pas
ans retrouvée pas dans la même situation
cette élection parce qu'il ya deux
législatives qui viennent en juin
macron en disant à quel point aussi il
durs assemblés du rassemblement national
se présente aux élections
macro pas toujours été prudent le
rien à voir avec celle de 2017 2017
doivent arriver on veut croire de son
autour de ma candidature à l'élection
décrire la loi mais je reviens monsieur
manifestations largement pacifiques mais
de sa popularité en tout cas depuis les
présent dans cette campagne électorale
cohabitation il il va faire avec
là mais vous dites c'était plus est
ceux qui prévoyaient ou espéraient notre
l'est la bataille pour les législatives
marine le pen qui est populaire et on
appelle des conventions citoyenne être
politique on peut toujours revenir on en
se demandaient bien sur wii où on avait
que j'appelle l'extrême centre et c'est
collective pour le mieux bon alors et un
haine ça existe déjà dans l'arsenal
tergiverser dès le soir du premier tour
qu'on réussit à les rejoindre et ce
ce qu'ils appellent la fracture de la
de la part d'eads emmanuel macron qui
nouveau par rapport à celui de marine le
progrès âges et horizons tous et toutes
sous-entendre attend en fait clairement
le bit et i té actionnant les premiers
que zemmour a pleuré tellement
ce deuxième mandat pour tenter de
s'adresser et même comment et configurer
faudra se méfier des illusions d'optique
lui donc avait évidemment du courage de
quelqu'un qui le 1 des télés journaux
malgré tout alors et on vote quand même
allait dire oui vraiment faire autrement
présidentielles et marine le pen au lieu
bref qui va diriger ce mouvement de
se trouve elle effectivement au centre
réussir mais il retrouve une france
visions qui sont très très différentes
dernière michel sur ce point et là c'est
redevient un jupiter com en 2017 je
fait par les reporters on entend quand
exactement pour laisser passer les bons
nièce de marine le pen qui avait rejoint
deux directions d'où la question qui est
défaite aux municipales ou régionales
qui roule et qui a entendu le discours
le candidat qui remporte la présence
ce traité pour accueilli à peu près 3000
énormes dix mille de plus qu'en 2017 et
sur un diplomate de ce niveau de cette
après ce 3e tour après élections
avant pourquoi prendre le temps de se
michel là dessus pour me reviendra la
important et ça emmanuel macron bon
gens ont passé en famille et c'est là
son attachement à l'union européenne qui
plus de 50 ans que je vote et je veux
avant donc des sentiments plus partagés
ottawa n'a toujours pas nommé
c'est qu'un tanguay ils refuseront de se
de leur sens du devoir
restera terminée et on va surveiller
vieux partis qui ont connu vraiment des
d'autres réactions à montréal
et s'il faisait quelque chose pour
pen qui s'est radouci l'oeuvre d'écart à
bataille des législatives le prochain
reconquérir l'union fait la force notre
très heureux on est très content parce
rare pour un cours pour être notée en
veut continuer de travailler sur les
plaisir à un certain électorat et la
autorisée les sondages les plus
américaines des élections de mi-mandat
qu'ont réussi à les intéresser donc au
nous sommes mesdames et messieurs en
qui est de la cire contre la première
les résultats qui sont d'ailleurs très
mais ça je pense qu'elle était moins de
haut la main de jacques chirac pour son
le sait fausse la représentativité
fait et vous voyez des appuis à emmanuel
vous n'avez pas compris changer puis à
besoins des gens qui sont au moins les
invite d'ores et déjà à les appuyer de
une grosse déception pour nous oui on me
voulait donner un coup cette impression
l'ambition si la france donc elle le dit
prochain voit déjà la constitution de
si c'est si ça vaut la peine plus tard
marine de guerre elle et marine le pen
le sentiment qu'il allait gagner mais
souvenez-vous il arrive seule la
caméras de micros tendus le pour
rassemblement on verra lors des
trudeau ça fait plusieurs plusieurs fait
le candidat divers
disant marie le pen qu'elle était à la
pour vous qu'il ya quand même une pente
de l'attaqué et ce faisant le président
a vu quelques-uns ceci dit là
et puis toute la question évidemment des
qu'elle ne serait peut-être pas le livre
ou est ce la mort de guy lafleur et
disparition
pierre pas loin donc avec moi donc voilà
sondages et les pronostics parce que il
dernière fois donc pas du tout abattu
technocrate en nacre on va dire des
capable de créer du consensus sur les
personnes géraient chaos - soit
france on l'a bien vu avec le gilet
dans les dernières secondes mais bon il
présidentielle
les français dans la rue à dire qu'il ya
exercée frappé l'imaginaire de zéro dans
présenter nous groupe plus grand se
législatif français
pen c'est à dire qu'il est allé chercher
ont souvent été émaillée de violences
attente de ce discours d' emmanuel
droit mais en hausse entre droit alors
l'a vue argumenté avec des électeurs
fait il faut remonter patrice à l'époque
cette concession mais on voit qu'au
d'ambassadeur à paris ce qui est quand
à voter pour marine le pen je priais
recoller d'apaiser les inégalités
l'entendue offrir un peu de flexibilité
différence avec d'autres d'autres signes
qui viendraient plus loin après la
appuyer les efforts qu'il faisait pour
lui a dit quand même quand vous parlez
le camp et zemmour en disant que pour
sa part parce qu'il était à apporter
exactement exactement et mai mais
allaient pas si fort que ce à quoi bon
français qui ont commencé ça aussi je le
ennemie lui même ça un peu plus que les
gouvernement parce qu'il va y avoir un
par combien donc les 58 pour ça qu'il va
enjeux importants comme la défense de la
question de la banque russe la question
ici mais voilà avec voilà exactement là
bon à montréal je sais pas si vous les
a fait de cette élection d'ailleurs il
dans cette défaite je ne peux m'empêcher
pense que la foudre ne tombe rares assez
fracture est quand même il faut qu'il
ses composantes de la majorité on a pu
de zemmour qui a entendu le discours de
voilà ouais interdiction pour les élèves
fort intéressant puisqu'il beaucoup
donc cette année le hier les français de
l'assemblée qu'on lui donnera alors y'a
voulu faire un prêt à ce moment là cette
défaite en elle tout le système contre
que oui à des défis recul y est on le
poigne comment le vietnam etc c'est
dos ils ces politiques nées dans pêche
la scène il est entouré de gens si ça
favorables c'était au tour de 57,5 a
légitime on peut se demander quel quel
réduire les fractures qui vraiment
de moins en moins et c'est bien sa
solde de vlad valdimir poutine rien de
fondé sur le travail
législatives quelle est la position
représenter après deux mandats il est le
législatives
de parler même reconnaît la défaite même
toutes vos forces et dès le 12 juin à
donc il ne s'est pas implanté et donc
niveau national on est quand même
même que c'est quelque chose qui colle à
jaune donc impoli militants ici et ceux
macron qui sont très forts on l'a vu au
donc les grandes décisions qui seront
de la rue si vous parlez à votre
droite extrême en tout cas sur
là pour défendre les intérêts des
est dans ce pays dorénavant le tiers
réformes institutionnelles il faut
deuxième mandat 82% contre contre 18
à remonter mais elle y croit et ses
relations avec la russie de la guerre en
parlementaire le risque de voir emmanuel
plus de six mois quel point qui a pas
la toute fin du mais quand même il faut
pratique ces deux shows mais c'est ça
a dit on ne peut se cacher lors les
dit que zemmour on va parler bientôt
macron dès qu'il parle on sera bien sûr
faut le dire les sondages donnent pas
et les chefs de guerre ah bon la puce
même étrange mais québec fera lorsque
effectivement est elle est effectivement
avez je ne sais pas on n'est pas en
choses qui peuvent avoir un effet
législatives
probablement un peu plus des gens qui
mais pour l'instant tout cas au champ de
prochain gouvernement relativement
évidemment elle invite aussi
prisonnières de salles assume ce côté là
l'est de la tva sur tout ce qui est
là-bas tenter de le convaincre il a
avait dit à la fin du débat un
une semaine de campagne d'entre deux
de mitterrand jouera même en 1981
côté lyrique à tout ça il ya un côté
michel ça a été ce qui n'est pas une
mais il maintient quand même le cap sur
depuis et quelques jours a été choisie
performances très mauvaise lors du
un problème d'identification autres
polis affaire privée c'est quelque chose
moyens parce qu'il veut briser sans
pyramide du louvre le là il arrive avec
faire aller à la rencontre des français
banquier est ce qu'ils aimaient bien
oui je me suis promené ici dans la foule
dire chaque fois ça a été un peu
toujours autour de 28 % ce qui dénote
et paris peut-être un petit peu
c'est avec l'ambition et bienveillance
les législatives
démocratie lutte contre les changements
autres
rapidement sur jupiter quelle belle quel
religieux est donc là et puis même a
d'eric zemmour est peut-être bien des
va incarner cette nouvelle droite plus
un électorat beaucoup plus éduqués la
ministre un donà lors des législatives
président de la république d'être réélu
deux baffes comme on dit et en même
trouve des solutions il faut qu'il
essayer de non pas de règle de régler
la peau des mains des manuels mâcon donc
présidentielle pour dit-il donner une
d'ambassadeur du canada à paris souvenez
madame le pen monsieur mélenchon qui
rôle prendra ce parti des républicains
encore aujourd'hui est très satisfait
coalition doit faire la france vive la
annoncées à partir de la formation d'un
premier tour on regardera les détails du
allés voter qui ont déjoué les sondeurs
pire c'est si personne n'a la majorité
et la création un projet de libération
l'échiquier ou droite plus dur parce
jamais il n'a été aussi près du pouvoir
nous tous les candidats du système
d'apaiser la france
pas une victoire éclatante elle dit et
essentiel ben voilà c'est ça c'est ça
deux grands blocs politiques autour d'
part de ceux qui ont dit non l'extrême
banque russe ses dirigeants sont réputés
encore pour me tromper
disait pour en parler au cours de la
complètement différent chez des gens qui
red écrivez moi qu'on s'attend à quoi
grande partie du revenu qu'on a à la
militants ses militants il croit aussi
il faut vraiment une espèce de coalition
tours marine le pen n'avait pas réussi à
méprisant un peu arrogant c'est un
aussi beaucoup fait saut chez les
un petit peu au-delà des derniers
de manifester de manière ostentatoire
moins on écoute
mission de la banque italie le canada
c'est un marqueur de son programme donc
entre macron et nous c'est la france est
trouvé mais c'est vrai que ce qu'il ya
odeur on n'est pas loin de 80 8% pour
de ressentir une forme d'espérance
se rassembler en laissant entendre qu'il
l'homme de la rue est ce président qui
voter pour eux rappelez vous mes amis
c'était
qui en ont contre emmanuel macron et
rapidement évidemment pour aussi lancer
alors pour cela il nous faudra être
alors on reprend d'un petit pause mais
mieux surveiller pour limiter les
années même suggéré avec une zone du
il est large parce que ça va du parti
qu'ils gagnent la majorité aux élections
voir voter pour emmanuel macron mais en
après les résultats vous savez ma la
fascinant alors aux charreaux à la
25e président de la république française
en direct je vais aller dire un mot avec
pour du tractage des événements publics
que tout le québec veut partager et tout
aucun doute son image du président des
nous sans nommer et mourrons mais elle
demande comme disait michel che qui
sans passer par une cohabitation comme
gens qui vont dire marine le pen elle a
sont arrivés et donc progressivement qui
mars est évidemment très calme vous
je joins on lui avait parlé il ya deux
climatiques et la croissance économique
dans le temps elle veut occuper encore
priori ce soir il fait plus ça veut dire
temps une volonté de l'humaniser oui
gouvernement on va surveiller tous vos
premier tour parti socialiste parti des
cette campagne ici lui a fait beaucoup
trouve des solutions
deuxième évidemment mais dans les
le fait que la retraite doit être
langue appel une élection de
du respect des différences qui se sont
c'est facile à comprendre alors qu'une
pour jean marie le pen les les deux fois
c'est ça un peu l'atmosphère patrice
référendum sur l'europe en mettant de
prochaine heure il reste que ça faisait
sont pas des technocrates exemple il y à
que ce serait c'est à dire si aucun des
marine le pen et chef de guerre elle se
mais il ya des
merci beaucoup année qu'à tout de suite
respiration démocratique au milieu du
d'un gros mal être au niveau de la
vous que le jour des attentats jeu du
oui oui même si c'est un moment
contre nous mais on ne doit pas rougir
emmanuel macron s'intéresse au québec
institutions françaises qui date d'il ya
que la famille ait accepté les
priori on ne voit pas comment on peut
les états-unis on vote beaucoup quand
très concret aussi monsieur macron tour
droite ce n'est pas pour la france s'il
qui est face à de sérieux ennuis
derrière c'est quand même aussi et
le vote à montréal hier vous avez vu et
me fait penser cette altercation entre
elle elle n'a pas voulu déroger parce
à agir et rassembler c'est vrai que
c'était au mois de mai quand ce visage
mathieu qu'il disait il ya un instant
il doit quand même se défaire de cette
après le dévoilement du résultat qu'à
de la droite et des gens qui en ont
bien c'est un avertissement ce résultat
sondages semblent satisfaire tout le
est jeune élégant robot dont on on sent
reprendre l'ascendant à convaincre
vous amuse vous errez après la peau
que prévu peut-être qu'on va écouter ce
retraite et c'est pour ça que on peut on
le rendent si non coupable en tout cas
combative et elle poursuit le combat
la bataille des législatives
les choses si c'était possible mais
monsieur macron à moins de presque 15
emmanuel macron et de jean luc mélenchon
se félicite de voir que des millions de
réalignement ya deux parties sur disparu
beau résumé christophe barbier rama yade
êtres des détails genre le droit d'asile
ce résultat constitue pour nos
qu'ils veulent se départir aussi de ceux
républicains ce sont des partis qui sont
même temps à voter pour marine le pen on
qui vont venir n'est pas gagner n'est
emmanuel macron à montréal on a une
entrées de deux étrangers illégaux sur
pour la classe moyenne ailleurs en
état qui peut tout changer
pour notre pays pour nous tout ce
serait le meilleur capitaine c'est ça
continuent d'arriver en fait maintenant
confiance institutionnels des français
on va y revenir alors j'ai précisé que
en avaient profité jacques chirac ou
moulin moto c'est eux qui ont développé
république et surtout surtout
prochaine en art pauvres merci beaucoup
de mal est ce qu'ils se disaient après
qu'il n'ya pas de fatalité quand les
augmentée c'est à dire l'âge auquel on
surveillez quoi laine dans ce qu'il dira
riches peuvent être capable de gouverner
quartiers plutôt cossu de paris les
une fois le pôle central de d'union des
exprimés ces dernières semaines je pense
vieille droite conservatrice
socialiste aux républicains mais c'est
électeurs de mélenchon à marseille ici à
je rappelle qu'ils étaient en ville est
quelque chose qui est assez vite
sa femme ils arrivent entouré d'enfants
particulier effectivement cette campagne
invite tout le monde à rejoindre ce
de poursuivre ce combat là elle dit je
le monde peut être est ce quelqu'un qui
boîte est très tôt aujourd'hui c'était
image là effectivement mais la crise et
partie de l'union de la gauche de
il va falloir à ce moment-là lancé des
des du phoning et puis l'aboutissement
très bien alors à licques de votre côté
que le tout sauf le pen a été plus
hélas oui alors il ya eu à cause de la
semaines adrien matou vous êtes
longtemps qu'un président n'avait pas eu
où c'est arrivé là sous la vème
on va monsieur mélenchon dont on a
de nos forces académique culturel
d'ailleurs le premier opposant à
c'était un peu empêtré et c'est dans ce
exigeant et ambitieux
les entends
reportages raphaël douvier au clair
apparaît sur les écrans de télévision
meilleur elle est plus difficile à
mois de novembre à paris quand même le
maintenant vous aurez drass horreur des
grands blocs dont on a parlé ce soir
arrive à faire passer cette idée là je
de la carte ou à peu près les
jamais gagné on s'en va chez zemmour il
plutôt bien un plan rona dans les
voilà on espère du côté du camp le pen
ressorti du débat de mercredi donc même
mandat et puis à la question de la
président qui très populaire donc là il
plus de 50 ans et pour ça il faut
on s'est rendus quand même assez loin
europe aussi cette réaction en français
françois mitterrand en revanche il est
contre emmanuel macron dont vous savez
que c'était un abandon en rase campagne
et qui veulent bien sûr entendre ce
l'inde peut-être et c'est amusant parce
monde c'est évident ici donc beaucoup de
l'avant ce que proposait marine le pen
mais en même temps des 41 % des gens qui
si on fait le calcul s'il ya eu un bon
pose comme pôle central de l'union des
français ont adhéré à son projet qui se
c'est seuil est très clair que là c'est
nommer macron gagnant évidemment pour
réactionnaires qui s'était porté sur
n'est pas tout à fait certain de sa bien
mais j'ai fait la campagne que je
possiblement comme policier avec vos
qu'elle a dit à ses partisans et au
l'une des premières choses qu'il a fait
dirigeants français comme pour les
république effectivement les deux fois
c'est évidemment un rôle que emmanuel
et je le dis avec beaucoup de gravité ce
les législatives lui en donne les moyens
le débat et qui devrait de plus en plus
accède à la retraite doit être augmentée
deux blocs l'un macro nist l'autre
gérard araud que vous connaissez qui est
je pense que c'est très important de
on est dans une république laïque
de sète qualificatif d'extrême droite
même proportionnellement en france mais
saint denis en banlieue parisienne
socialistes et les républicains qui sont
participation en hausse par rapport au
de table ce maquereau qui dit aux
qui ne sont pas les les cieux
développement
monsieur mais sont finalement ont voté
gilet jaune n'a pas aidé
s'il se rassemble s il s'élargit
banlieues où les choses se passent bien
vais continuer à protéger les français
peut dire bon 65 ans nous en a 65 ans
en tout cas c'est bientôt au revoir
signaux la nomination du prochain
qu'est ce qu'on fait il ya des
le territoire ça a donné lieu ça aussi
drone mâle se dérouleront demain on dit
français déjoue les pronostics continue
rioz des balles sur le nucléaire mais on
important que le tout sauf macron ça
pas acquis
merci beaucoup de paris hélène e et
soir après 20h selon lequel des deux
mouvement oui tout à fait et aussi
très intense beaucoup de déplacements
comptable de cette fracture qui s'est
malheureusement pour les français c'est
dans son fief de hénin-beaumont donc
en fonction depuis mai
restructurer la gauche et lui comme
annick sur place
quand on est entré dans notre premier
pandémie un certain nombre de rendez
bataclan et tout ça ce trio est obligé
nous avons tant à faire
probablement plus tard parce qu'il y en
mais quand emmanuel macron lui a cité
ce avant les américains donc ça leur
joindre à elle de comprendre son projet
reste de la france très bien on va aller
dirigeants européens le témoignage d'une
pense que son mandat commencera mieux
différentes régions de france qui ont
proportionnelle doit-on réformer le
quant à quant à l'avenir de l'union
comprendre pour des électeurs je pense
françois mitterrand porte la gauche à ce
beaucoup parlé avant lui était pas sur
c'est d'abolir l'impôt sur les grandes
réseaux sur youtube et cetera il était
ya des gens qui ont déjà commencé dans
week-end là que s'est cristallisé le
vous cette dame est mal vu que le yen ça
entrepreneurial
bien qu'ils ne partagent pas les
ce qu'elle va dans une heure et demie
tenter de leur tendre la main faire des
droites si quelqu'un doit faire cette
les régimes autoritaires ou libéraux les
une déclaration de guerre à marine le
c'est important de l'impression qu'il
ça a été ces deux tours de l'élection et
macron va continuer à poursuivre jusqu'à
etc à 65 ans et de beaucoup à 65 ans qui
monsieur mélenchon comme il l'appelle
associer tous les partis qui souhaitent
les présidents ont été obligés de
dans le texte de son allié le pré
contre l'insécurité contre les
échangées le pouvoir pendant 30 ans ça
discours les gens qui j'ai parlé il y
ça aussi la difficulté c'est comment
alors on va écouter en direct les
invités en toi vi nations mais espère
il aura la liberté pour le faire puisque
conventions internationales
aller prendre le pouls de ce que pensent
annick le disait beaucoup de terrain il
autant au rassemblement national qu'au
pour madame le pen est quand même une
c'est comme si ce sujet là
droites ça c'est ce que voulait faire
françois fillon la dernière fois et qui
s'il a dominé je pense qu'il n'a pas
une bonne partie soit par adhésion à
on a entendu le discours de marine le
un autre débat sur les signes religieux
soit parce que ça pour notre pays c'est
a plusieurs qui vont s'abstenir par
le premier à être réélu dans un
souhaitais faire et ça déjà c'est une
indivisible on ne doit pas normalement
a voté vers 1h heure locale mais par la
mandat on a beaucoup beaucoup agi on
fortunes ne suce ne s'entend pas le
fort c'est d'accord elle gagne ok avec
premier ministre ou de la prochaine
vous manqué entre les deux pays nos
économiquement de paris encore une fois
que les électeurs ont répondu à son
entouré de jeunes il va féliciter on le
mais met à expliquer nos élèves
présentent comme des patriotes avait
collaborateur notre émission souvent sur
n'a pas parlé beaucoup de crises
préoccupations de nom de la rue il a eu
je pense que tous les français n'ont pas
français j'ai eu et j'ai conscience que
nombre de personnes sont allées voter
premier tour donc moi je suis très
bref l'expliqué non un pouce et
de garder espoir et nous donne les
pen avec bien sur l'emballage de il faut
l'union populaire à lui faisait bon ben
l'état donc le premier mesures d'une
veut dire que le barrage républicain
certainement on a on a été perçu comme
n'ont pas voté pour lui vont pas se
patriote qu aucun démocrate ne peut
comment est comment on a réagi la ce
aggravée pendant cinq ans il avait en
autographiée guy lafleur chaque pas dans
l'écouter merci beaucoup à tout de suite
européenne dans le contexte actuel c'est
que s'il n'entend pas ce message là je
vote le débat télévisé qu'il a perdu
grande défiance du peuple penser à leur
arriver et forcément il va traverser la
la liste mais avait un rôle à jouer un
2017 et il avait battu à ce moment là on
mélenchon n'a par la chute comment la
au débat vous allez l'entendre à un bon
même à voter pour marine le pen
l'heure là les gens commençaient à
et la garonne créé n'est là pour nous
ressemble peut ici vous me direz mais
quinquennat c'est le premier néanmoins
islamo-gauchiste deux blocs qui
ce projet ce projet je veux le porter
eric zemmour m'a vexé 7% il est moins
promesses à gauche par exemple sur les
en tout cas contribué à rénover la
puis là on s'est attaqué à l'espace
musique beaucoup d'entrées et puis on
bien emmanuel macron qui a été élu
ministre britannique boris johnson
marine le pen soit par colère rejet des
cohabiter de partager le pouvoir avec un
totalement seule la dernière fois au
des excuses correct c'est il ya comme
la fin du mois de juin tant que la
l'exemple
les français établis au québec établi à
l'abstention était un sujet d' analyse
avait un peu de tout dans la dernière
nécessaire pour le remboursement de la
système électoral pour permettre aux
une hausse dans l'est par rapport à 2010
reviennent à cause du tour de france
meilleurs amis sont arrivés ceux qui
désintérêt pour les deux candidats mais
comment répondre à ces extrêmes en
t-il toujours bien sûr gouverner avec sa
convaincre assez de français qu'elle
parti re conquête on refuse on rejette
s'est ponctuée évidemment pas ma part ce
lancé cet appel à des périodes tant de
une mauvaise nouvelle parce que vous
première ministre
union des droites ça se fera autour
le 12 et 19 juin en vous appelant à mes
compris le projet de marine le pen il
mitterrand le fait chirac l'a fait
heureux de ces résultats en amérique du
être complètement balayé de la carte aux
et puisqu'ils ont élu un président
hier pour la gauche ça a voté macron à
politiques d' emmanuel macron parce
mettre ce soir à dire tiens tiens il va
ans à toutes les présidentielles à
pour les français montréalais alors on
semble-t-il au premier tour donc un
climatiques par cette campagne dont vous
avait une majorité au parlement on avait
propositions elle en a effectivement
national qui ont commencé à lécher les
vraiment fait bouger les lignes ce débat
sirois début de conclusion ce
merci bfm
proche du pouvoir c'est en fait un
une fois de faire campagne sur sur autre
mais quand on va ailleurs le scénario
me fait penser et c'est des moments
pen de monsieur zemmour j'imagine ça dû
a trouvé en eric zemmour
fort intéressant évidemment aussi avec
interdira toute personne et la loi de
aborder les cinq années qui viennent
avec une nette amélioration à montréal
moyens de les défendre le score
suite ça c'était au touquet en bord de
appel parce qu'elle a lancé un appel aux
de la mer d'un légionnaire qui a été
symbole que c'était pour les petites
accepter tant le projet d' emmanuel
verdir charreaux bonsoir bonsoir ou
l'importance de ce qui s'en vient les
pour il parle plus vite que prévu je
anti extrême droite fonctionne encore en
2017 il avait dit
fois donc sous la vème république sauf
feinter presque 2 décrivez nous ce que
france à la présidence de l'union
que la droite face à quoi ici on est
mais qu'elle n'a pas perdu par ko comme
demi-heure des gens qui sont venus ici
rôle à jouer se voit déjà premier
volait c'est ce soir aux français sont
premiers ministres respectifs ne se sont
cette illusion d'optique de l'exploit ne
constitution lui interdit d'en faire un
égard qu ils ne peuvent ignorer et celui
félicitations pour la réélection nous
dit
débat qu'est le le point d'orgue de
échange parce que c'est le terrain de
général il donne au président sa
voit absolument félicité des proches
organe de blanchiment d'argent est ce
france et puis il faut aller chercher
et à
des mots des petites phrases
milieu de nulle part dans nos d'humour
france insoumise s'est effondré vous
discours de madame le pen avec
c'est à dire que les gens qui voulaient
nord derrière les résultats sont très
manuels macron et qui ont voté contre
public mais on ne parle pas de signe
vous n'avez tous nos pauvreté pour moi
d'elle c'est ce qu'elle dit ce soir à
s'organise se rassemblent et s'apprêtent
plupart de ses dépenses électorales a
foule puis ça va être assez
qu'elle leur répéter ce qu'elle a
aussi une question démocratique que
est d'environ 10% la wiwi de 33 à 42 %
vais y avait du jeu vous et quand je
croit lui que le président sortant a
577 députés à l'assemblée nationale en
cohabitation avec ma grand et on imagine
généreux de son temps pour ça alors je
l'étiquette d'extrême droite surtout de
beaucoup moins parler de l'immigration
fort qu'elle donc l aile préempte ce
que il ne s'agit que d'une légitimité et
business cette colère la haye après le
élections aux élections c'est important
j'ai bien vu que durant ce second tour
une espèce de réticences à avoir
sarkozy est passé près mais n'a pas
premier ministre qui n'était pas issu de
eux avec la guerre qui secoue l'europe
majorité à lui et pour sa doit
montréal donc je vais vous présenter
l'impression d'avoir été élu sur un
savez quand on s'est quittés il ya deux
gens alors effectivement si on est un
puis d'autre part il ya des choses qui
patriotes de droite comme ceux de gauche
suscite beaucoup de mécontentement au
tous mais à la fin elle a quand même
bravo vous me laisser toute la place
européenne --après parce que la france
priori oui plutôt on a fait barrage à
droite que de gauche elle dit aussi que
l'entre-deux tours mais la dynamique des
discours-là qui manifestement les boules
oui parce que tout le monde se demande
troisième il aura sept libéral liberté
espère que les gens peut aller voter en
1905 et qui fonce chez nous la laïcité
gouvernant au centre et on parlait alors
mais quand même il y avait des esgaulx
charnières dans des campagnes
direction le directeur de la rédaction
madame le pen au cours de la campagne du
rappeler que nous traversons des temps
gérard araud par les livres c'est c'est
pense qu'elle veut
macron sur le régalien ou le social
particulièrement malheureux dénoter une
parler en notre nom il va être il sera
complètement différent par exemple dans
historique de ce soir place notre camp
bons on est à un peu en dessous de 90%
en 2017 mais plutôt au point le débat
martelé durant la campagne elle reproche
sommes vous êtes un allié l'un des
quand même demandé à la population aux
montréal puis bon sur ce devoir et ce
chose
certains égards qu'il avait mal compris
prédilection de marine le pen et elles
doit pas cacher que sa victoire est
sommes nous donc condamné à perdre
que françois mitterrand quelques années
eric zemmour s'est pas eric zemmour avec
majorité mais je ne suis pas sûr que
cette ère nouvelle ne sera pas la
pour le second tour de l'organisation
votaient makoun ou pas forcément changé
législatifs qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
lui qu'on donnait plus de 40% des voix à
semaines patrice on disait que pour
etc ce sont les polonais également il
que ça vous plairait qu'un dirigeant
secondes s'écoulent et sur notre compte
soutiens j'ai reconnu un ou deux
pense que c'est complètement mérité
de sa pire année comme un roi et là il
vous ai entendu exactement il ya une
virés l'ailé les mots qu'il va avoir
mon but est aussi de réduire l'extrême
assassiné par mohamed merah et
débat marine le pen a beaucoup martelé
la part de marine le pen qui a tout fait
tenté de dire moi je suis pour une
faire pour attirer ces juin de ces gens
l'assemblée nationale il aurait pu le
parce qu'ils ont voté manuel macro mais
spectaculaire avec la musique un peu à
programme qu'il fallait mettre en place
s'en souvient marine le pen avec 66 32
continue à se voir comme une grande
parce que ça a été le pré carré d'eric
vous voyez
de comprendre saint-michel cesser le
les jeunes les jeunes aujourd'hui il
il ya des colères qui sont réels il faut
dépendez de monsieur poutine parce que
france il en faut donc la moitié plus un
est en train de dire un mot
tragique où la france se doit le porter
france ça veut dire aussi que le plus
portrait sourire en vue projeter quand
en terminer avec ça ce qu'elle va
grand nombre
de l'aspiration largement partagée d'un
rôle là quant à jean luc mélenchon il
le nord de la france dans des
possible le système va lever beaucoup
sauf que emmanuel macron lui a quand
courte face à l'extrême droite ne pas
savoir sur quoi ils comptent ils
français face à un emprunt à la cosa
plus tard je le disais tout à l'heure a
bonjour je suis à new york ou à vous
alors aisé mot est beaucoup plus presque
convaincre des gens de continuer à voter
aller chercher les électeurs de gauche
à s'affronter dans un match qui n'aura à
d'un chiffre ou est ce qu'il ya une
alliés les plus proches et les plus
économiste c'est probablement pas une
leurs réponses vous allez voir les gens
lire comme premier ministre je vous
de l'express merci nous avoir parlé un
emmanuel macron avait essayé à nouveau
est ce que tout ça c'est de la science
certaine sensibilité une certaine
chiffres est clairement en faveur des
elle craint un devoir que le prochain
où ces gens je serais allé s'ils étaient
au président ce repas est maintenant
réussi à faire ça et non plus pour les
leur bord politique et c'est exactement
fait plus de 40% des voix lui en a fait
ministres il y avait clément bonne il y
reste clivant et pour la france
joué sur la peur donc pouvait
à rebours emmanuel macron sera-t-il le
en oui est ce qu'il le fera à lui de
comptent
défaites le nom de le pen est accolée à
lui fasse son apparition ici là pour
macron vise et très concrètement qu'est
encore une fois pour essayer de dire à
très vite et assez vite après presque
pour dédiaboliser ce parti après avoir
n'est venu que confirmer ce qui avait
la loi de séparation de l'église et de
des relations avec la france
envoyer le message que je vous ai
l'américaine comme on l'avait vu en 2017
ses 7 % même avec sa nièce marion
qui se sentent isolés qui se sentent
de le pen est accolée à trop de défaites
de la quadrature du cercle
donc dans la région de pas-de-calais
faire pendant son mandat ils l'avaient
le peuple et qu'il était trop basse et
cette fois ça soit ça soit si clair que
de plus
importants je suis heureux de continuer
fracture j'ai et je dois résoudre
marine le pen donc c'est un
continuité du quinquennat qui s'achève
en 2010 on a dit qu'il fallait interdire
d'attirer les électeurs entre autres de
été obligé un contraints de cohabiter
la guerre en ukraine évasion russe et le
quelques mois après avoir dit cela
dans d'excellentes dispositions pour
les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
tiers tiers
othello tient mordicus en france comme
lien ce cordon important
alors on va écouter monsieur zemmour
que vous savez de dire vous voyez
fiction ça se peut
pour pouvoir et bien faire passer les
faut reconnaître on a eu du mal à les
faire plus de 60% c'est pas énorme et
chose alors vous vous présentez pour les
nation on a beaucoup parlé je vous
zemmour pendant cette campagne avant le
territoires ouvriers minier ben là
ukraine libre c'est pas vrai que j'ai
allait bientôt début de la campagne
une excellente campagne de premier tour
produire la prochaine fois annick quand
droite là dessus il a échoué puisque ils
bonne mesure d'infos sur les grandes
c'est la technologie tour de france qui
mais cette image de confiance de
plusieurs mois voir alors j'ai pu la
dur reste à faire pour emmanuel macron
arrivé une fracture de la france dont
grand changement les français
l'inaction écologique de monsieur macron
êtes à new york comme nous bonjour à
marine le pen c'est ça
l'avait déjà dit avant le second tour et
dans cette brèche là que veut
sont soulagés ici dans la métropole
comptent appuyer gouvernement à vin bien
même rappeler que par exemple il y avait
taxi à paris à hélène c'est d'ailleurs
qu'on appelle la fracture sociale qui
à travailler ensemble sur les sujets clé
allés voter ils sont habitués à ce
certains alors le petit le partenaire
totalement différent comment dire
veut montrer qu'il est proche de ses
avec ce avec les deux tours aux
quinquennat va se poursuivre sous le
le président des gagnants beaucoup des
manuels macron regarder ça c'était les
ce que l'argent donné par un petit peu
de créer de la division à nouveau en
annoncer dès ce soir qu'elle démissionne
premier président être réélu depuis
journée
rejetés par le système pour les
court / qu'un seul perdant la france le
la ferveur donc tranquillement ici ça
macro milieu mélenchon à gauche
été déjà consolidée par le week end
et vous avez quelqu'un avec vous qui
l'instant il est toujours à l'elysée
avait donc tout à coup c'est un homme
je leur laisse 7 cette épithète mai mais
avertissement peut-être pour le prochain
madame le pen avait fait faire des
promis c'est finalement retenu un moss
convaincre qu'on portait un projet aussi
pris les rênes de ceux de ce parti pour
y at il une fatalité pour que les idées
madame le pen vous avez contracté un
rôle qu emmanuel macron un jeu alors on
le verdict des français à 14 heures
l'insécurité extraits le dis très
macron s'ils gagnent peu importe le chip
ça est par ailleurs nul ne sait
voir à lui de voir
avec un grand enthousiasme en tout cas
ce que ça veut dire s'il n'y arrive pas
ensuite cas il vient d'arriver j'ai pris
voilà michel ses premières impressions
représenter la présidente de son du
très bien merci alors on écoute monsieur
très forte du côté de monsieur trudeau
66 il passe à 58 n'empêche
obtenir un grand nombre de députés en
vraiment pas reluisant pour ce parti
ce avait été assez frappant de cette
jean luc mélenchon même s'il est soumis
maréchal-le pen qui a rejoint eric
fortunes parce que ça fait des
date en tête mais en gros il aurait dû
des liens avec poutine s'est malgré tout
premier tour il était beaucoup plus
mais l'invention collective d'une
emmanuel macron il n'est pas du tout
leur ancien ambassadeur je le rappelle
entendu même si j'ai cinquante huit pour
par ailleurs il ya une immense colère
autres qui dans la plupart des cas ne se
législatives mais c'est un fait que dans
pu faire autant saignements qu'elle
qu'ils aient ils voter ces nouveaux
appelle en vérité à faire vivre un
cohabiter avec qui cohabiter avec un
intéressés dans la chose politique alors
législatives et d'ailleurs monsieur
de dissimuler son visage pour des
ça me paraît très peu probable quand
dont acte cette banque a fait faillite
c'est tout près 1 ça va prendre cinq
faire en sorte qu emmanuel macron soit
deux ans on a frappé la fameuse crise
l'instauration du cadam marine le pen
projets de loi autrement il faut rentrer
laisse avec le prochain rendez vous pour
où elle a fait le plein de ses voix elle
sa voix
certaines certains problèmes sociaux
la défaite ça fait 8 fois dit il et ils
emmanuel macron a été méprisant à mon
manifestent ce soir le souhait d'un
signe du mépris c'est ce qu'elle avait
tracts électoraux avec une belle photo
s'engouffrer jean luc mélenchon il l'a
intentions de vote au soir du premier
projet là alors il ya quand même 28 % à
campagne en 2007 quand il y avait cette
cette participation voit des images au
entouré ce n'est plus le président voilà
réaction cette fois en allemand dans le
leur ressenti leur ressenti profondément
trop à gauche justement un petit peu
attirait indue du premier tour et des
populaire c'est une marine le pen qui
militants de ses partisans on va
notre invité précédent gérard araud il
tous ces électeurs et non pas seulement
gagnants le cercle est plus grand pour
ce que le président va viser évidemment
prêt en 2015 auprès d'une banque russe
mineur ce devrait être réduit et là ils
se retrouvaient évidemment avec marine
sûr les législatives michel fait quand
est un crime
juin prochain la passion de l'avenir qui
l'extrême droite a droit cette logique
certaine neutralité mais aussi la
connectés avec leurs salaires sans s'en
précédent et qu'elle suit vous voyez un
avait été employé pour la soirée
se voir plus souvent mais il ya une très
zemmour même avec des gens qui sont
quinquennat mais assurément pour les
la voiture il vient d'arriver à paris
mélenchon a demandé aux électeurs de les
avait dit pas un vote pour madame le pen
demain être l'opposition à emmanuel
de notre et la clarté de ses choix
elisa l'art vous êtes comme il ya deux
verra ce qu'il dit dans son discours
les émois premier ministre est ce que
écologique qui souhaitent le faire qui
dans une espèce de cohabitation de
58 c'est vraiment beaucoup plus qu'on
réélu je vais essayer de célébrer un
dans ce moment vont-ils aller davantage
c'est ce qu'il faudra surveiller dans le
fait ses discours alors est à dire des
zemmour justement et on revient
une personne retraitée qui avait dit à
sociale dans ce pays on l'a vu avec le
pouvoir partir plus tôt ça tient pas
sont même pas représenté voyant qu'ils
elodie et elle a bien raison c'est
nationales perdent toutes les élections
certains d'origine maghrébine j'ai vu
savourer et puis on verra demain je
seul en tout cas si elle remportait
l'absence d'un ambassadeur c'en est un
sera t-elle la première femme est
aujourd'hui c'est une bouteille à
quelqu'un à voir en lé code pénal
ça dans les derniers jours de la
contre-pouvoir fort à celui d' emmanuel
arrivent souvent en première position au
d'histoire justement françois mitterrand
dit le plus clairement du monde élisez
apparaît à plusieurs endroits en france
j'ai j'entendais une de ses ministres
des gilets jaunes qui a montré que cette
beaucoup dénoncé dans les derniers jours
raisons de sécurité dans l'espace public
des choses qui constitutionnellement ne
donc d'un côté on est soulagé que que
toutefois le coeur du projet de marine
minutes en voiture à peine et puis là il
en 2016 un patrice mais la créance de
certain jacques chirac qui est devenu
d'elle et vladimir poutine il y en avait
aux gens en france en israël à l'onu
ça se pose est que tout va bien dans ce
ferveur quand il traversait la france
que des très riches mais des gagnants il
pour les petits gens c'était à c'est le
les personnes qui voient avec tristesse
vous c'est l'insee c'est bien résumé
les deux coups de la droite
législatives très bien merci sylvain
profonds niche mais en même temps une
les français c'est important les
vers l'extrême droite que va-t-il se
carrément un grand virage écologique
l'alimentation bon mais c'est très bien
aux 27 % du premier tour à tous ces
électorale à l'époque avec les lier
ils vont passer les deux prochains vous
déclaration de guerre et en même temps
méthode fondée pour cinq années de mieux
macron et qui ont pourtant contribué à
et met par ailleurs ils reprennent à
seul jupiter est oubliée jupiter je ne
liberté de conscience et de croyance
l'écouter bien sûr merci merci chers
texte on sait que madonna qu'on est un
discours ce soir
beaucoup de français et qui retrouvait
clairement immigration anarchique et
connaît pas le le sentiment profond que
nouvel avenir en commun pour notre
bonne relation entre le québec et la
petit peu ça ensuite dormir dessus comme
campagne ça va jouer très fort pour
l'encré nulle c2c ne sait aujourd'hui ce
c'est d'avoir une nouvelle majorité
même un petit bout que je trouve la
si tant est qu'elle échoue comme prévu
est décédé à tirer avec des propositions
le pen au second tour cette élection et
nouveau le pourcentage d'abstention
comment ça se passe parce qu'en fait la
divisée et marianne va nous annoncer le
souhaitent le porter
en reprochant emmanuel macron une
fracture elle existait en france comme
score de mélenchon on le voit avec le
c'est possible ça va être compliqué mais
coalition et ça en france on n'a pas du
premier tour et à jean luc mélenchon qui
l'heure où législatives elle n'est
bon il se voit dans les jets celle ci se
choses comme par exemple il gagne plus à
tenait pas la route et puis tout le
pen marine le pen elle est quand même
vous avez entendu cet échange sur
tout à leur accorder une entrevue un
souvent systématiquement que partenaire
partis des républicains pour aller chez
allaient être battu ce n'est pas
nous anime nous voulons la mettre au
pied depuis une dizaine de jours une
pense qu'effectivement ils vont pas
législatives
une nouvelle campagne et cette fois-ci
traditionnelle et la mini de la gauche
président des riches et ça c'est une
semaines dans un rassemblement à l'union
est détesté par une partie des violences
passer avec marine le pen et les députés
parce que c'est elle c'est pas pour rien
politique je pense que je n'ai jamais vu
son premier ministre et puis les 2 1
macron d'une opposition qui va continuer
france on l'a vu notamment au moment
hélène il a en tête quel quel
y en a qui se reconnaissent pas du tout
fervent défenseur de ce qu'on appelle le
aujourd'hui la perception c'est que
en même temps en nous des hommes et on
jake locker au point vous êtes un
vous ne parlez pas à d'autres dirigeants
moi premier ministre est une formule
86 avait changé la loi pour introduire
pays oui humble et rassembleur
donc je serais dit il le président de
palais des congrès pour améliorer la
proposent une coalition mais d'abord il
qu'il a fait et il l'annoncé pendant un
je veux dire ce soir ma déception et ma
revenue sur mélenchon de chagrin comment
peu près des électeurs français qui ont
dans tous ses mythes et où on l'a vu en
sortir en faisant des grandes
fois retourné à l'elysée il va voir la
le réélire nous serons sûrs le seront ce
monsieur malone et touche pas ma
avoir beaucoup de temps pour savourer
fait beau c'est vrai tout se faisait
qu' elle n'est que la fille de son père
mélenchon qui pourrait restructurer la
douche vous pas je vois que les gens
monsieur macro très bien on va aller à
parce que si nous si en france nous
il faut unir la droite la
est arrivé au deuxième dans les
merci annick parent qu'on voit les
peut-être ça sera ça mais on ne sait pas
l'état détruit et le pays vendu à la
score de le pen il y à une poudrière
le pen effectivement et elle a déjà un
on voit le la date 12 juin un dimanche
rester à la maison quand français qui
électeurs j'ai entendu ce que vous
puis surtout tout son quinquennat et
normalement protège de cela oui raphaël
enfin la prochaine période attendre des
depuis tout à l'heure avec cette
image qui lui a collé qui lui colle
les français pendant cinq ans un
désinvolture un mépris pendant cinq ans
automatique d'être réélu une deuxième
réseau français disait nous sommes
sur le pouvoir d'achat baisser la taxe
ce soit quelle suite vous voyez pour le
c'est ça il y avait un politologue
chez le pen quelques réponses simples en
ceci dit l'union populaire donc le
long de l'après midi vous les connaissez
traditionnelle et les mines et dans sa
comment la gauche va vouloir se
service de la plus belle ambition qu'ils
on dit et puis réfléchir à mon avenir
nous en avions dit un mot tout à l'heure
eric zemmour non c'est moi ce soir qui
voit dans les dates dans des choses
elle existe aux états unis au royaume
tout la culture de ça on n'est pas
s'affrontent pour la présidentielle de
regarde bien le nombre de
opinion parce que c'était pas très loin
bord nul ne dispute son sens éclatante
dans ce court de victoire aussi court
et de bâtir sa force dans tous les
financement de son projet elle dit avec
arrivent des côtés ils sont dirigés
quinzaine de jours de la part de
majeur ça doit être moi je suis pas sûr
que sera le pôle le paysage politique
mon âge dans ma 65 le général de gaulle
parce que et entre la bataille des
ne pas être capable de suny voulons nous
au service de notre pays de notre
voté pour lui au premier tour qui ont
retraite pouces avait fait dérailler une
marine le pen est allée entre les mains
peuple
moteur franco allemand pour la en europe
l'interdiction du voile voulue par
les québécois recensement voilà c'est
consultations nationales et a permis
banlieues autour des grandes villes donc
puisque on n'élit pas le premier
est là qui peu importe qu'il dira peu
française à montréal d'ailleurs faut
se console parce qu'on regarde que c'est
alors qu'une majorité de notre peuple
qu'elle est là je faisais ça qu'il faut
travaillent sur on a déjà entendu des
assemblée dans le nord dans le sud où
contents mais humble alors c'est
habitué serait redit à notre émission je
fracture sociale avec autant de gens qui
britannique qui a parlé vous savez de
fois c'est un phénomène
rassemblement à marseille a fait le
encore à la peau les symboles semble pas
qu'on oublie un petit peu c'est que si
circonscriptions
cadrature du cercle à faire parce que il
à les défendre et à les protéger face au
de la proportionnelle aux élections
vous avez vu cette masse d'électeurs se
notamment la crise des gilets jaunes a
c'était encore un peu
président de ne pas se comporter comme
m'avez dit j'ai entendu mon premier
sociale en france et emmanuel macron va
propose ne pas partir lui de pas aller
vous parlez à votre banquier quand vous
dans ses déplacements dans ses fiefs
de l'assassinât de samuel pâtit ce
résultats à l'elysée comme tu es louer
encore elle ne tient plus parce que
images monsieur macro qui va arriver
marseille qu'il allait nommer un ou une
liste des gens qui sont beaucoup plus
italien oui on n'est pas allemands c'est
vous vous êtes dans un bureau vous
effectivement il a quand même lancé cet
l'un d'eux joint bonjour bonjour
à vers les français et ce qu'on a
quelles que soient les juridictions
courage action
ministre en france mais donner une
mouvement dont il se réclamait pour
d'autres entreprises dont une entreprise
comme ça mais malgré qui on pourrait
uni et dans beaucoup de pays occidentaux
augmentation de la participation au
mais voilà ce sera l'histoire des
réarrangent et maintenant est absurde
sais pas quel est le dieu grec ou romain
bon bref hélène
de moi je vais vous dire pourquoi c'est
français dans les mois qui viennent
fois en france comme président vous
dans lesquels vaincu l'enfant est arrivé
expliquer aux gens ce n'est pas pour
dire ça mieux voter hier je pense à
2017 c'était 66 contre 34 c'est quand
tranquillement mais l'espace au
de vente la retraite à 60 ans après 40
avait été réélu avec 55 pour ça ça vous
marine le pen qui a précisé que cela ne
adhéré donc la lnd faisait référence à
rassemblement national
qui est
88 puis dans ce débat qu'on voile en ce
d'étouffer un peu le mouvement puis
centre de la france il était toujours
tout cas
législatives qui commence effectivement
l'insécurité dans notre pays on a pu
choses pareilles si ça n'a aucun sens
fait 43 % c'est autour de moi que cela
d'inservio même mais
partie de la campagne des conservateurs
de l'opération de dédiabolisation opéré
sommes aussi dans un système
nouvelle gauche vous y croyez c'est bien
les 16 milliards d'économies qu'on va
aux extrêmes maintenant monsieur
parlez de la russie c'est ça le problème
législatives pour empêcher la droite
que ça va fonctionner très fort chez le
dit je referme la parenthèse son ado de
les quartiers plus populaires ben là
tous et de toutes les françaises tour de
militants de la part de diluer da par
dire que c'est confirmé si vous avez
pourcentage monsieur macron pour dire
le score le plus jamais atteint là c'est
c'est un truc ça aussi avec le terrain
dans quelques minutes est ce qu'il
oui tout à fait comme la question des
dans les endroits qui avaient voté
mandat où j'ai voulu effectivement
ça donc il faut choisir entre maquereau
première ministre dont la première
ça a été un moment difficile pour madame
voilà sera pas du tout facile ce patrice
se joindre à la famille de madame le pen
importe comment il est habillé et
intelligence il est brillant et tout le
qui était entouré de tout le monde mais
a fait beaucoup de promesses entre les
découpe
à dire les allemands il ya dix ans nous
s'ajoutera une alliée en europe par une
rien que le franchiseur le feront que le
qui faisait beau à paris aujourd'hui
tristesse
montré qu'il y avait une parlé tout à
dès demain matin et puis et puis ce qui
qui a été condamnée pour avoir vendu des
surtout retenu de son discours c'est
professeur d'école qui a été décapité
alors oui je croyais aux miches dit le
mais elle s'en vantait jusqu'au moment
qu'à montréal lors du premier tour eh
prochains jours pour l'instant les
jeunesse chacun d'entre nous il y aura
c'était pas triomphal du tout comme
pas bien de voter marine le pen et cet
aidez nous à comprend est ce que l a
parlementaire c'est à dire que le
ceux qui sont moins est ce qu'ils se
majorité à la france un soumise à
correspondante du monde et radio france
sa résidence de président bien sûr car
qu'elle veut proposer par référendum aux
disais il veut que son premier ministre
voilà il peut se retrouver à devoir
peut-être le mot d'ordre pour cette
alors il faudra voir quels jusqu'où le
après c'est arrivé là mon avis faut pas
faire sur le dos si je puis dire des
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui s'est
concernerait pas par exemple la kippa ou
majoritairement pour réellement gay
voter davantage mais ça s'est mieux
délitement de leur pouvoir d'achat face
donc elle est un peu pris avec ça
mélenchon d'un côté le pen obtient
être très important pour lui pour sûr
moment il ya cette phrase qui est assez
l'idée d'adhésion qui ont adhéré à son
travaille au plus qu'à l'appel c'est pas
le disais alors premières impressions
à toutes et à tous je dis ne vous
d'avoir un raz-de-marée parce qu'il
ans de travail etc donc est-ce que ils
comment il est entouré il ne passera pas
les gens seulement qui sont ces gens là
accepter dans notre pays que pour un oui
madame le pen alors le raccourci est
n'empêche pas ce que oui on a dit tout à
mission accomplie quand même le plus
donne est une des cantons darryl à 58
bien que nous ayons été des millions à
donc élections législatives et on verra
ils en veulent terriblement chez
pas du tout un échec et sylvain vous
réforme est allé vite il a sans doute
deux tours sur l'écologie est un
voudra aller parmi la foule plutôt que
marqué la nouvelle ses sorties à peu
voyez ce champ marche qui va s'activer
dire que le trudeau et macro se
doit se faire revenais à la maison et
détermination refus toujours de la
de tours et ça c'est très cruel pour les
soirée peut-être pas de grand coup
prochaines heures c'est franchement
appel je vous entendu alors maintenant
oublier mais là il faut qu'ils disent
imposé donc on voit clairement que la
accueilli comme une sorte de vedettes
continuer à agir parce que l'objectif il
mission ce sera d'accélérer la
prochain président ne peut pas gouverner
discuter avec les écologistes avec les
bien les électeurs s'étaient tourner
l'heure de cette colère sociale mais
soit aussi responsable de la
qu'elle n'a pas du tout l'intention de
sont dit oui c'est à dire ceux qui sont
ce qui viendra ici donc au pied de la
ou la france dont elle espère peut-être
discours c'était je suis conscient des
pen cette histoire là mais
monde le sent et le sait et puis ils
en ce en se fondant madame le pen il dit
eric zemmour de se présenter aux
le pen et le débat et cette rencontre
même assez large mais pendant ces deux
l'union populaire lors des législatives
nous la france ce soir ce soir je le
pareil et ça il dit qu'il ya des
déroulé on avait parlé la console ya
là tout à coup on est ensemble on est
ce moment qui est assez savoureux où
que cela ne concernerait pas par exemple
immigrés des étrangers qu'on va soit
même très très peu et en plus on sait
macron et jean luc mélenchon
proche de 60 on a fait une grosse
alliée davantage que ne l'était monsieur
français et elle veut modifier la
beaucoup en france et d'ailleurs le
l'étincelle s'il n'a pas compris ça s'il
vivre la démocratie et pensez vous qu
armes en syrie donc voilà pourquoi c'est
qui comprend tout ce langage là twitter
parce que là on dit oui ça va être
rassemblement n'a jamais fait fait
discours complet à cran au dessus à
ou pour un non on vous blesse ou
on savait qu'ils avaient un désamour là
programme politique mais il ya quand
chancelier olaf scholz il se réjouit de
aux atteintes aux libertés face à la
sentait qu'il y avait une opposition qui
table raphaël à paris
leur propre à la france mais est ce qui
oui c'est beau c'est un peu voilé mais
est ce que je vous ai entendu ça veut
sur le rassemblement national
monsieur zemmour de l'autre mais c'est
attend le futur président on a peu parlé
près 1h30 2h guy lafleur aura des
mélenchon aux communistes qui était avec
elle a émergé on l'a vu ça a duré des
ça c'est vraiment un enjeu qui revenue
qui va accueillir
cohabiter à devoir inventer en tout cas
d'éclat on veut garder les pieds sur
l'heure puis votre collègue barbier
raphaël hélène et michel sur le voile
musicales ben on va essayer de recréer
de la france
et emmanuel macron sera obligé de faire
mille hommes avec 59 c'est bien
transition écologique je pense que ça
que ce message là auraient été entendus
législatives aussi pour vraiment
tour eiffel il ya toute une organisation
planification écologique et ça c'est un
peut élire jean luc mélenchon premier
les religieuses catholiques qui
petits partis madame le pen
baisser les bras elle a même je pourrais
ajustements la galère mais je commence à
sans une majorité à l'assemblée
êtes toujours là à
est bon c'est presque un cliché de mes
la personne qui est heureuse après cet
jacques chirac lui dit vous n'êtes pas
bien dans la mondialisation qui envoient
fois c'est un rematch est ce que c est
aller on a le sourire pour les content
allard nous sommes à cinq minutes des
vouloir en finir avec le quinquennat
arrêté de m'arracher des bund
manqué un certain nombre de concertation
dire je vous ai compris ça c'est ce qui
jeunes politiciens ils ont quand même
que patrice il faut dire que ier des
électorat-là de 7% des mois il a quand
communistes avec le petit parti nouveau
pour elle comprend mieux si jamais ils
représentent et c'est cela sa force et
personne est le message des manuels
emmanuel macron votre ami elle est
si monsieur mac on va réussir à aller se
je ne le veux pas nous sommes des
semaines l'écart n'a cessé de
montaient ça a été doublement un échec
difficile les travaux d'hercule il faut
remise en cause de nos services publics
divisions c'était aussi je vais changer
d'enjamber comme ça le deuxième tour en
après les élections législatives
le président qui je vous le rappelle est
résignez pas au contraire
est quand même d'atteindre le plein
constamment quand on parlait aux
même des gens qui vont avoir voté pour
deux semaines beaucoup de soucis de
avec cette dame qui portait le voile
zone assez étroites où on prévoit
terre rester humbles pour envoyer un
commence son deuxième mandat en pensant
ce soir parce que ce n'était pas l'enjeu
constitution marine le pen chose qui
fatalité et de la résignation
pourraient continuer de se promener donc
est la raison c'est ce qui lui donnera
mais c'est vrai que dans cette campagne
ensemble et donc vraiment la mise en
autant dans les sondages et dans les
macron michel sauget hélène qu'est-ce
gauche et en même temps pourquoi il faut
eux lors des deux dernières élections
de descendre comme un roi dedans à voir
continuer à travailler avec lui et
mois avec quand même des exactions
il fait très beau alors il n'y a pas de
la france est soumise donc vers la
violente on vous sautent sur la tête où
le président en ce moment je ne suis pas
représenter une troisième forte une
pour pour quelqu'un qui est centrée
entourage envisager aussi la suite des
monsieur legault avait immédiatement
c'est un message fort qui va falloir
châssis ogi vous étiez à paris au
concept qui est très cher à jean luc
on doit malgré tout hélène michel
système québécois qui est adoptée
emploi de lutter sur l'écologie de
des alliances parce que c'est pas donné
le dire se noie et c'est ça qui est bien
disait oui mes illusions d'optique s'il
un caillou dans la chaussure de marine
nationale et le premier ministre doit
leurs enfants étudier à l'étranger qui
suffisant pour lui tombe bien sûr parce
8 députés l'assemblée nationale les
résultats vous êtes je l'appelle un
puisque la droite a gagné et le front
dire le couteau entre les dents quand
sylvain n'empêche je reviens pas en
devant la tour eiffel
humilité et promesse d'une réinvention
faire barrage des gens qui n'aiment pas
et de notre système social
parce que là les gens se disent quand
de la part des électeurs qui voulaient
d'entre deux tours
d'électeurs et et n'oublions pas elle
il a sans doute manqué un certain nombre
macro ont beaucoup de difficulté à
l'insistance avec laquelle on en parle
après midi ce soir là bas c'est monsieur
jeux était président de tous les
que tout lui est possible eh bien il va
qu'il y ait à l'appel d'un fracture
potable atomes crochus crsa faut noter
reste à voir parce que moi j'ai trouvé
d'ailleurs il recevra emmanuel macron
aussi à 5 ans donc on se dit il ya du
modeste et makro
funérailles nationales le mardi 3 mai à
revient c'est dans moins de quoi moins
gauche on parle de plus du tiers des
d'emmanuel macron ce soir les amoureux
aides sociales et tout ça aujourd'hui
même fait 7 % des voix elle va en avoir
avec leurs habits et leurs six extérieur
pouvoir a tassé deux à trois mille
sujets qu'ils ont quand même rattrapé
de moi le premier ministre je vous
sa faiblesse la france qui va bien c'est
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que jean luc
parti anticapitaliste de philippe poutou
finalement ce second tour mais des
premier tour donc j'avais béni on à la
parce que s'il est porté par ces mots
s'accentuer regarder ça c'était juste
traduire dans les actes
message justement à cette partie de la
se souvenir les gilets jaunes ça vient
force d'opposition peut-être même la
que le chèque est ce que vous suivez
d'ailleurs si c'est l'autre exemple si
votre premier ministre ou sommes deux
un peu cette ambiance et ça s'était
cohabitation et d'ailleurs il ya eu un
c'est que fait toute sa carrière
français
chercher se bâtir une majorité ou pas
s'inspire un peu jusque avait été fait
rassemblement à l'union française de
pluie c'est ce qui compte et puis tout
issue pour faire des parallèles voiture
on espère vraiment parce que ce serait
intentions de vote et dans les votes
ne le comprenais pas parce qu'il est
même personne de 75 ans qui a porté le
s'avère probablement très compliqué ou
vive la france vive la république
que ça dit aussi le monde l'ogcn
j'ai envie de dire c'est peut-être moins
image est totalement différente 2022
voyagent qui qui progresse etc et puis
le pen le rassemblement national lui
gagne quand même mais quand même s'ils
sociale très bien mais il est quand même
s'ancrer dans ces milieux où il s'est
parce que les freins sont quand même
n'a que cinquante trois ans c'est pas en
mac ont divisé vous tant que vous voulez
apporté son soutien à la france alors
au devant de vivre désagréments et
pour son parti votait pas totalement ce
millions à ne pas le vouloir le bloc
que c'est ben c c'est un vote
national en 86 a fait élire 35 députés
d'ambitions notamment pour lutter contre
appelle chez nous l'opposition
elle lance ceux ci on peut écouter un
que dans ce discours si effectivement il
vaillants faut 15 pour être en partie
du tout cette idée d'augmenter la
politique basé sur l'occupation du
celui du port du voile islamique dans
pouvoir
transformer l'école mais il va falloir
on recule mais qui avait démissionné
terminé vous rappelez peut-être en
candidats et françois mitterrand lui
rappelle quand même que justement le le
macro et les leaders de la planète donc
face au recul premier par emmanuel
c'est arrivé souvent c'est pas arrivé
essaye on dire moi je reviens juste s'il
avant le débat de mercredi 56 44 et ce
dispose bien des gens c'est que bon il a
on cherche à vous assassinez ça n'est
menées par ces gilet jaune mais aussi
relations internationales de la russie
sentiment de ne pas pouvoir boucler les
d'une demi heure une demi heure très
progrès ça envoie un message envoie un
qu'il ya des des troubles réel créé ça
c'est très différentes il est possible
personnes
sondage assure trois personnes 3000
dans 50 jours gagner une majorité c'est
entrer dans l'action
de fatalité
est en plein air c'est pour ça qu'on
force principale au sein de l'assemblée
sans vouloir exagérer l'importance de ce
s'organiser à droite parce que sinon
besoin marine le pen si elle veut à son
vous voyez ces images à libérant il
population française à laquelle faisait
à dire c'est qu'ils se sentent à l'aise
oui donc les législatives c'est quand
aujourd'hui particulièrement
et bien et est issu de cette majorité
et conquis qui était déjà acquis à sa
elle qui a raté la marche qu'emmanuel
gagnent ils gagnent mais oui et il n'y
soient de droite de gauche de nulle part
reconnu les socialistes qui sont quand
demande fin de cette campagne
réélu
président ce moment là bon raphaël
retraite de la manière dont emmanuel
après un référent référendum exactement
devant l'espace que vous voyez
législatives qui viennent vous après les
nette au sort du 1er tour beaucoup plus
arrière il réussit l'exploit car même de
démocratique c'est-à-dire qu'il a
jean luc mélenchon ensuite de ça c'est
c'est parfait soit engagez vous et
la cathédrale marie reine du monde à
officielle le contre-pouvoir
il ya un accord qui est en train de se
en france mais madame le pen il faut le
montréal ça y est ils auront comme nous
une taxe carbone on a augmenté les prix
nous avons des raisons d'espérer
doit lui a emprunté 13 millions de
rejeté les deux extrêmes aujourd'hui
france et déjà qu'ils sont présentés
de la france ont perdu et emmanuel
répond vous avez tout à fait raison
qui continue à faire la guerre en
macron veut relancer la filière
fallu il a fallu il n'a fallu beaucoup
de porter par marine le pen oui très
s'il devra cohabiter
voile toute sa vie
peut-être impossible en fonction de ce
tour qui a pas été à la hauteur
je sais pas comment mais de la politique
frappe à chaque fois depuis quelques
apothéose devant le musée de la pyramide
petit peu ce qu'est la laiterie à six
message à emmanuel macron comme quoi y'a
petite soirée de célébration je pense
nationale alors que jean luc mélenchon
vraiment tragique pour la france que
macron de l'âge de la retraite face à
2017 oubliez tous ont fait autrement
souvent alors maintenant elana raison ce
mais karen et des parallèles issue
jeune il
rendu il faut le dire quand même dans la
plus possible bon les migrations quand
nouveau président réélu emmanuel macron
10 ce chiffre là est faux parce qu'en
changer de méthode le président l'a dit
personnes qui montrait que 66% des
présidentielles il ya un effet très très
l'urgence
mais oui c'est quand même c'est quand
précisément au fait qu'on aura les
centre politique c'est presque un double
ceux qui se sentent normalement d'un
serré et actuellement dans le faudra ça
fins de mois de trouver qu'année après
tour élargir notamment en vue des
et il s'est retrouvé françois mitterrand
reconnaissait et l'abstention et le fait
l'espace public celui aussi de ses
dans la globalisation qui parlent deux
évidemment de leur ambition est ce qu'on
pour johnson justin trudeau le prochain
macron le propose alors ça je pense que
national doit lui aussi s'unir et se
référence patrice ces gens qui se
évidemment la légitimité aujourd'hui
ukraine de la situation de l'europe des
même qui était une force celle ci à 5h25
franchement massivement la démocratie
beaucoup plus tard que ça dans leur vie
faisait référence à un peu tout à
quand même pas complètement fait on a
cause pendant qu'on voit des images de
sommet que monsieur truc monsieur
monsieur le premier ministre il remporte
voilà d'aider des choses qu'il a dû
mais c'est difficile de se vendre à ce
tant à gauche qu'à droite qui ont aidé y
d'abord la marche de victoire parce que
montréal une chapelle ardente aura lieu
bien je j'ouvre une parenthèse on va sur
parti comme je les dis reste très
qu'on va faire avec lui on voit se
lui a clairement les yeux rivés sur
donne le champ libre à mélenchon puis à
ainsi si si si les socialistes et les
moi je vous dis c'est vraiment quelque
pour nous convaincre d'en parler de ces
monsieur legault au dessus du parti
dollars à peu près à 6% de taux
quand même un fort pourcentage des
justement va aller voir quelqu'un qui
marine le pen repren le pouvoir donc
militants
probablement derrière mon pied de la
c'est ce que joue jean luc mélenchon
l'heure c'est un échange qu'elle a eue
leur réponse
aura pas de remise en cause de sa
net qu'il ya cinq ans pour quand même
programme marine le pen parce que c'est
débat qui a duré deux heures cinquante
période de l'entre-deux tours il ya eu
même une étape cruciale pour monsieur
sentent délaissés par la mondialisation
voilà et je suis sûr que dans le
française
ça va dépendre de l'ampleur de sa
trouver le problème c'est que pour
l'insécurité à l'immigration anarchique
à la présidence ça c'est après un des
année cette situation là elle est pire
aura une entrée à l'assemblée nationale
faut dire que c'est quelqu'un qui n'a
français souhaitent qu'il ya une
a promis que son futur premier ministre
pour gouverner encore une fois après la
c'est un dossier qu'il faudra surveiller
en cohabitation avec jacques chirac
toujours vu dans la vème république
que disent les constitutionnalistes elle
résultats
macron a été réélu aisément il est le
g7 est prévue en allemagne à la fin du
nous lançons ce soir la grande bataille
reparler roland lescure merci beaucoup à
rassembler davantage les françaises et
relations avec la russie en général et
législatives
deuxième si on veut une marine le pen
légitimité en revanche ce que les gens
réalité les immigrés ne coûte pas plus
même ça qui est important d'abord
du louvre donc c'était c'était donc très
marine le pen en provence sur un marché
chose de grosses sommes alors voilà donc
va prendre beaucoup de temps qu'on voit
quand il dit je vais imposer une
oui parce que manuel macron dans ce
fort de soutien au président qui vient
problèmes là très bien madame le pen on
vous savez arrêté me parler de ça mais
ait eu quelqu'un qui est très
notre parti reconquête est fort de cette
ce duel en 80 vite donc il rempile pour
un reformatage complet de cette campagne
ma croûte on sent que la guerre est
se faire réélire
village de et qui ne vont pas bien du
français qui ont cru qu'ils soient par
trudeau quand il a fait sa tournée
c'est un portable ça nous donne des
les gens qui ne se sentent pas
qu'il faut voir c'est qu'ils vont être
l'entendre de ce ras-le-bol de ces
son audience et son électorat est
toujours aller beaucoup plus loin on va
qu'il ya une colère sociale dans ce pays
député sait presque rien dans une
langues qui voyagent à l'étranger et qui
au cours des prochaines semaines des
est du côté de macron roland lescure que
l'instant les socialistes sont à
québécois monsieur macro lui est issu
macron là il doit il trouve hélas assez
largement un fan club qui n'a pas qui
raphaël je reviens aux résultats ou
que ce ne soit pas un vote d'adhésion et
d'intérêt est ce qui fait dire au
vrai que finalement tout au long de
encore quelques minutes et puis on
pires 11 ans comme bouée en politique
exactement et on sent la fébrilité dans
jamais été élu aussi on a toujours une
ou les cartons ce sera pas juste à
que l'année précédente et la fracture n
niveau là donc il a les coudées un peu
aujourd'hui comme disait le député
rassembler notre responsabilité est
veut y inscrire ce qu'elle appelle la
tentations illibérale qu'on voit partout
cette bataille législative on l'a
républicains si les vieux partis vont
très très bonne en bottes 4% des voix
vladimir poutine en particulier les
les français donner une majorité au
discours qu'on attendra y aura beaucoup
désenchantement démocratique mais aussi
l'itf on a l'impression qu'elle était
son premier ministre qui vaut aussi est
serait en charge de la planification la
confortable au centre il faut pas que ce
indications pour les législatives qui
cohabitation au futur président puisque
et au laxisme judiciaire
le terrain voir marie josée paquet
l'extérieur de cet accord très bien
prochains mois parce que ça pourrait
sujet que vous vous le voyez constamment
on verra si la majorité ou pas à
les français tentaient de créer une
rassemblement national à l'assemblée
ouverte dans le camp nationaliste mais
peu vu finalement d'en avant le premier
ou pas donc on voit aussi que toutes les
représentés par la classe politique
qu'il ne rapporte au budget de la france
mois de juin deux jours autour du du 26
peut nous donner de nouveau le moyen de
électorale des législatives plus que
chambre de 566 élu alors le système
voter macron à faire barrage à marine le
la prochain merci à vous et à bientôt au
qui peut être
discours a bien souligné qu'il est
ça y est il a réussi il est installé pas
personnellement assez usés troisième
les gens ont voté ou un peu patrice
européenne en pleine crise de l'ukraine
vraiment aucun problème c'est un peu
émissions de co2 cette taxe carbone il
colère envers le président ce quoi par
cette campagne qui a mené au premier
bataille des législatives s'il a une
pourra je l'espère célébrer la victoire
quand même du monde socialiste il a
et président de la république avait été
l'élection législative compétents que ça
présidentielle souvenez vous à l'aube du
être un des premier véritable test sur
les colères et les différences etc j'ai
responsable la transition écologique
maintenant jusqu'à il ya cinq minutes à
de l'importance de cette élection
spectaculaire cette fois seul est
nationale c'est pas un prix d'ami 6%
gagner l'élection et il ya une
faibles cotes d'écouté de l'histoire de
plus franche que on aurait pu le penser
faire un petit signal évidemment à jean
lescure
française déjà cette image qui est quand
faire un petit état des lieux debout on
tout et on a en france aussi beaucoup
ce qu'on appelle le mix énergétique donc
prisonnière de son propre programme oui
préférence nationale
d'alliés pour former un gouvernement
est pas qu à ce niveau là patrice on
sert viennent après le 3e tour comme on
réussir à sortir leur épingle du jeu ou
présidentielle qui avait été élu en 2017
un nouveau septennat et on passe en 81
vous connaissez député des français
président nouvellement élu quoiqu'en 88
rafael vous êtes avec nous d'abord
entendu dire qu'ils se prennent qui vous
dans le monde ça aussi le président
cartes vont se
en effet je crains ce soir que le
sujets qu'elle avait quand même
intéressant parce qu'ils élisent alors
depuis onze ans on pourrait regretter la
confort là ce soir ne se traduise par un
sont allés voter pour faire barrage ce
oui mais raphaël ce qui ne veut pas dire
de ces élans à l'humilité à l'appel aux
pen donc a priori ce serait pas étonnant
majorité il sera tout à fait légitime de
comeau devant le centre bell j'en ai
des élus de terrain avant il avait été
classes populaires et de ces classes
profitons-en c'est une victoire qui est
puisque les questions écologiques risque
revoir alors oui sylvain desjardins et
n'a pas gagné vraiment d'élections et
failli changer d'idées sur le sujet mais
à quelle hauteur messieurs macron se
je serai n'ont pas élu premier ministre
qui va falloir attendre un tout petit
sont qui espèrent que finalement
la salle je voudrais que les locaux de
jeunesse cette belle jeunesse militante
adhésion à ce que madame le pen aux
démobilisation des électeurs des gens
transition écologique ce qui était très
introduirait quand même un peu de
tour elle a surtout mis de l'avant des
premier président à avoir été réélu sans
en début de journée quand on 04 55 à peu
conscient qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
premier tour il n'a presque pas fait
juin ce sera dans les alpes de la
immense
peut-être encore un peu plus parce que
certaine forme de coalition des
ça c'est un cheval de bataille de longue
nuageux mais enfin l'atmosphère est très
pas michel c mathieu prost hélène merci
tour et pillay il s'y est mis
identitaire qui est liée à l'immigration
en est sur la laïcité en france mais
travaillé avec monsieur aulas il a créé
l'assemblée lors du troisième tour des
peu près évidemment les gens sont
dit d'abord c'est important deuxièmement
entend aussi beaucoup de gens qui sont
ce genre d'exercice d'exercice avec
donc nous n'avions pas le choix c'est ce
luc mélenchon qui lui même est engagé
12h à 20h et le dit de maisdon de 10h30
moyennes ce n'étaient pas les plus
l'attitude et la direction politique que
revenons à l'essentiel pour ce qui
peu quand même parce qu'il ya une
établis hors de france et porte parole
cette colère la est réel ce n'est pas
n'y a pas 10 millions de façon on aurait
macro puisqu'il est réélu ce soir va
parce qu'elle a fait et monsieur mais
parler d'eux en tout cas
même assez forte montre ce qu'il veut
parlé mesdames et messieurs tout à
au départ les gens réalisme ont demandé
monsieur mangematin qui me va tout à
c'est pour cela que j'appelle à l'union
campagne monsieur macron il a beaucoup
maire il avait été député oui vous avez
politique toute sa vie on dit s'il
se verrait bien dit comme premier
par le nucléaire à l'horizon 2050 il
mais il y aura une majorité de gauche
oui bah il faut il faut élire une
qu'il n'ya pas un problème qui est
frais il ya quand même une fracture au
vous êtes toujours ce rassemblement
l'abstention c'est le joueur le plus
roger
ont voté pour lui non pas par adhésion
élection qui normalement attire tout le
c'est la tour eiffel je vous rappelle
l'union française à montréal sont
second tour ça va être compliqué pour
pas trouvé qu'ils avaient quand même
qui n'ont pas qu'ils n'ont pas gagné ce
électoral va favoriser je suis accroc
bavière dans le sud de l'allemagne alors
changer de cap
qu'ils ne veulent plus entendre c'est de
proportionnelle il faudra voir l'effet
ce monde polique certainement français
c'était une majorité relative en plus
maintenir peu le système tel qu'il est
cher à jean luc mélenchon alors voilà à
voleur dans les faits ne pas écouter ce
volontaires pour transformer la france
pour nous mettre en bouche petit extrait
enjeux économiques liés aux frustrations
il y avait beaucoup de nouveaux les
très net une victoire de 17 points
d'être très importante dans ces
insatisfaits qui se sentent laissés de
serait comme comme chef mais et il était
législatives et ce soir il sort de la
l'heure on a eu ya quoi trois heures
pauvres des français qui manifestaient
dans la bataille des législatives mais à
sociologiquement de ce bloc élitaire
qu'on ne peut pas comme ça mettre sous
son mouvement que rallier une partie de
15 ce visage qui apparaît ici jacques
de repartir pour un mandat mais encore
beaucoup de signaux très clairs
est si enthousiaste note
urgence ce sont les législatives et en
de voir quand même une grosse partie et
date d'abord de son père jean marie le
2 de mad d'influer sur le marché la taxe
de république en marche le parti des
quand on lui a rappelé au début c'était
voudra prendre emmanuel macron pour la
près ces trois points là ils valent très
tour parce que dans cette volonté de
pour rien que madame le pen se retrouve
misé sur son rôle de chef d'état très
très bien là il n'y a pas de doute les
et marine le pen aujourd'hui se retrouve
que nous avons fait et ils ont été
quinquennat qui s'ouvre ne rompra pas
remplis des lecteurs français qui
donc aujourd'hui c'est effectivement
sein de la france à laquelle emmanuel
est ce que madame le pen vont passer à
montréal vous êtes avec quelqu'un qui
aujourd'hui un mot quand même sur cette
devoir et bien prendre ça en compte
que ça va avoir pour le retour du
gens qui n'ont pas voté pour lui alors
élections législatives là et ça va nous
des hans en même temps auparavant
pour pour françois mitterrand sauf que
un lors de la crise des gilet jaune
ressenti par beaucoup de français
montrer que rien n'est laissé au hasard
pour l'anecdote qu'il avait demandé à
possiblement assurés soit la victoire ou
le troisième tour comment ce soir les 12
souhaitent une union avec le
les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon se
voudrait que ce soit 50% 50% nucléaire
tout à fait vrai vous allez être obligés
nouveaux marcheurs on les avait appelés
l'heure que c'est très symbolique le
raison de dire qu'il est arrivé un peu
suite des choses et c'est très concret
pour sa proposition politique mais pour
voilà nouveau raout politique
majorité des députés il ya 577 députés à
côté particulièrement des jeunes quand
présidentielle finalement après la
beaucoup mais pourquoi il ya tant inès
sortir d'une période de cohabitation et
dans cette dans cette élection si la
suivre c'est assez rare pour être
beaucoup pour cet après-midi éclairé
pen et puis donc d'elle la fille marine
quotidiennes des français on en parlait
obligés de le refaire cette année pour
voiture et il est totalement libre comme
envoyé à ceux qui justement n'avaient
en la projetant vers l'avenir on a deux
cher et maintenant c'est comment il est
fait là ce qui est en train de se jouer
maintenant les détails des funérailles
important que ça s'adresse comme si on
contre le bloc populaire on a bon le
montrer de se montrer plus aide aussi
avec les pratiques méprisante et brutale
tout l'enjeu pour emmanuel macron il a
nationale en vue des législatives nous
c'est un peu le candidat du statu quo
puis à d il ya des parallèles
gens sont rassurés et puis monsieur m'a
quel point la réconciliation après des
impliquée dans le conflit en ukraine or
et donc voilà libéralisme a subi une
tenu de ce que vous avez tous se
manuels macron première réaction
c'était des travailleurs peau les gens
législatives
qu'il faut interdire pour elle
cas sylvain on a vu la voiture monsieur
à 15h on peut s'attendre à voir beaucoup
choix du champ de mars pour emmanuel
septennat avoir bonne chance en tout cas
et parmi ces nouveaux marcheurs il ya
cet électorat qui une fois de plus a
zemmour il prend pas ça dans le ciel il
d'interdire les signes religieux de tout
l'époque d'utiliser ce site ici de voir
au deuxième tour pour la deuxième fois
macron devra vraiment s'adresser devra
une fois s'il ne veut pas laisser la
donner aussi un aperçu de savoir est ce
très clair que eric zemmour lui voulait
qui se dit d'un côté comme de l'autre et
avec logique macron il va sans dire son
avait au 1er tour voter zemmour oui
tourner vers un vote utile sans
il aime comme sujet tout le monde
chirac donc devient président remporte
effectivement dans la situation où elles
de nulle part alors ça veut pas dire
on parle des questions liées à
rassemblement
quand même un très très bon score à ce
réélection d'emmanuel macron avec 58%
souligné et on le soulignait aussi dans
plus empathique aussi le plus proche des
monde alors vous avez raison on voit une
le pen la préférence nationale qu'elle
raconter brillamment tout à l'heure en
j'aurais pu vous dire vrai ce sera les
les factures d'essence ni facture
pour eric zemmour comme pour marine le
monsieur lescure sur cette ré élection
candidats quand ils vont accepter leur
et 50% d'énergies renouvelables il veut
faire barrage à l'extrême droite c'était
répondre à ça oui mais c'est aussi une
france il peut faire les rassemblements
la campagne présidentielle
traduit en mots atom politique comment
du précédent et qu'emmanuel macron ne
dans l'entre-deux-tours il s'est rendu
réelle fracture au sein de l'extrême
france dans le même état que il
carbone en interne et en est une il y en
internationale pour le président réélu
le monde on fait pas dire juste l'islam
réussir à faire une union de la gauche
intéressants ne serait ce que sur la
colère qui se sont exprimées la colère
emmanuel macron et c'est ça qu'il va
l'assemblée nationale il faut avoir une
un parti vous l'avez dit qu'il ya qui
vous avez été très bon mesdames et
convenir façon son allocution avec
qui voyaient l'ascenseur social qui
la gauche une partie de la droite
des gens formidables qui se sont révélés
beaucoup de gens qui vont vouloir aller
préliminaires de cette élection
conviction pour macron afin de faire
alors même que sa personne faisait
macron puisque comme il veut représenter
bien sûr regardé les résultats dont les
racistes oui le le programme qu'elle
c'est intéressant parce que je suis allé
nationales pour guy lafleur le 3 mai et
n'avait pas accepté qu'on votait à 70 72
qu'il ne venait pas de quelque part il a
appelle maintenant priorité nationale ça
pas un emprunt dans une banque russe
vers une modernisation dans un monde
des étincelles
désaffection dans toutes les grandes
il faut il faut quelque part c'est
donc le dernier septennat puisqu'on
moment là elle peut réorganiser
voit parler chez fran le voit parler
pas voté pour lui au premier tour se
socialistes où ce sera les républicains
fait barrage quand même contre l'extrême
parce qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
qu'ils veulent avec les petits partis à
un des groupes auxquels il s'adressait
d'épicerie et on parlait beaucoup moins
dans le nord de la france d'en haut pays
trouver des solutions et on parle pas
dire à elle va perdre après ça moi je
pen c'est qui prend le leadership sur ce
épouse mais des jeunes la simplicité pas
la tour eiffel pour sa soirée électorale
électeurs ceux qui ont regardé ont donné
droite qu'on a vu m après 2017 parce
studio il reste que il ya tout un
on verra je reviens madame le pen et à
a capitalisé sur un sentiment
messieurs on se retrouve demain nous 17
macron qui est au centre du jeu et il
devoir faire passer d'une façon ou d'une
qui ont aimé ça et puis aussi beaucoup
président réélu pour cinq ans tout à
nos invités c'est la première fois qu'un
français qui s'inquiètent de la fin du
barrage de la marine le pen maintenant
droite dans ce dans ce premier tour
en essayant de convaincre les autres
étaient bloqués ce patron des petits
a pas dix mille autres alors casse en
miser beaucoup sur le solaire sur
également donc ici un peu assis au
laïcité ce serait intéressant de
il est traduit pour les élections
fera rien pour réparer les fractures qui
défaite se réjouir dans leur victoire ça
législatives déjà et se tiendrait dans
majorité soit tout seul soit avec
l'apprend aujourd'hui ou en tout cas qui
cette fois c'est un emprunt dans une
s'appelait en marche et la république en
chef d'actes mans et c'est vrai que
présente est un programme d'extrême
emmanuel macron très bien mou sur
défaite et j'ajoute que c'est la même
on l'a souligné depuis 12h30 c'est quand
amusant parce que évidemment compter des
grande question c'est combien
présidentielle qui devrait être être
l'espace public sous peine d'amendés
qui gouverneront avec le parti du
faire un reportage cette semaine à
entre les deux tours emmanuel macron a
victoire pour l'europe cep cette
juste le voit le voile c'est qu'elle
droite c'est à dire que ça va au delà le
dirigeants qui sont très écologiste dans
l'union européenne et qu'il est parti
veut dire quoi ça veut dire les français
sont efforcés de voter pour lui au
l'objet d'un rejet massif par nos
certains s'attendaient à des gestes
et qu'on lui avait refusé c'était la
passe après ça des mandats de cinq ans
minier dans le nord de la france où
il a aussi reconnu qui a un taux
tout à fait ici en ce moment du
travaillé avec françois hollande vous
monsieur émaux techniquement pourrait
c'est sévère madame le pen on a beaucoup
vais aller chercher les restes et c'est
sainté célèbre en france les fois je
antilles françaises saison
50 jours on n'a jamais vu depuis six
autre ce soir paris de la mise en scène
facteur qui est le niveau d'abstention à
mois donc le pouvoir d'achat c'est ce
d'insécurité par un sentiment aussi que
emphase tout à l'heure c'est certain je
france et on rembourse une partie
camp nationaliste lui revient à sa
banque hongroise pour sensiblement le
atlantique au mans 12 vers un monde un
et la colère de gauche avec monsieur
vous faites ça je vous le dis en toute
patrons d'eads et des employés qui qui
marseille puis on parlait à des genres
législatives mais madame le pen à 41,8
président est réélue sans avoir eu à
la reprend aujourd'hui en 2022 il y un
marche qui de 2017 à aujourd'hui a
heures bonne fin de dimanche véronique
n'y a pas eu d' étape à paris voilà
élection là parce que elle est remise en
l'ukraine avant de laisser l'antenne
vraiment décortiquer
était aussi incarné par eric zemmour
vont s'abstenir des libertés parce
de ces enjeux qui sont historiquement
encore un coup de barre en direction
lui faire un dernier salut on y
d'abord et ensuite tous les citoyens
pour europe et bien être devant la tour
l'avais dit à l'elysée mais justement ce
dévoilés vers 14 heures environ et pour
d'autres partis l'objectif il est de
président mais quel sera le résultat des
marine le pen est très populaire dans
voix dans une petite municipalité ça
divise notre pays et font souffrir nos
vers 2 c'est quand même un score
second tour
d'abstention qui pourrait être l'un des
la suite des choses pour l avez vous été
sauf que jacques chirac deux ans plus
sincérité je suis en train de vous dire
milieu en voulant prendre toute la place
bien compris que c'est un irritant ça
le discours qui ne sont pas du tout dans
cumulative elle distincts peu comme si
de gens soient qui n'ont pas très bien
troisième tour comme on l'appelle des
chose en slovénie il ait eu aussi des
des pluies aux législatives et là
moi qui va devenir le porte parole de la
en 2017 il avait quand même fait dans
vous ai compris là dedans même si c'est
prendre la parole après ce 12e tour là
savoir combien vont le faire et combien
mélenchon il va falloir porter et
mois mais c'est très loin
contre vous il joue contre vous et ça
compatriotes
chiffre qui va être intéressant à
côté techno il est un banquier il ya
même rare mitterrand le fait chirac l'a
ce que proposent les candidats ont
ce que les gens vont vraiment aller
question par beaucoup de gens en france
liés à sa formation politique on en
cohabiter avant voilà merci mathieu puis
mais bon c'est un discours de soirs de
d'emmanuel macron regarder au lendemain
vote d'adhésion et encore on avait déjà
mairie de paris qui lui avaient refusé
jean luc mélenchon est arrivée largement
qu'elle avait ciblé depuis le début de
de dents volé est pas arrivé au dessus
grande idée qui est de dire qu'il faut
vous rapelle que au cours de la dernière
plus importants depuis la fin des années
même montant environ 13 millions de
les cités autour de paris s'est rendu à
reviendra un peu plus tard dans
monsieur et maquereau ou si on s'est
monde globalisé ce n'est pas totalement
aussi cette espèce de de haine parfois
qui n'ont pas été assez ambitieux selon
la réalité est ce qu'il est ce qu'il
qui ne s'en sortaient plus et qui disait
certain nombre de politiques qui
législatives je crois que les militants
important
républicains récupérer ceux qui sont
que la france patrie des lumières de
qui veut l'emporter à pour des raisons
eiffel c'est une image qui très forte
prend pas de temps qu'on te d'ivoire
compatriotes alors oui pour éviter cet
immigrés du reste du monde ça vaudrait
socialistes et et des républicains
que cette retraite de nouveau allongé
compris pourquoi comment ça fonctionne
que va-t-il faire que va-t-il dire en
son duel avec marine le pen était
élections slovénie la majorité libérale
vous n'avez pas votre ceinture de
droite c'est très clair que c'est son
beaucoup inspiré de d'abord du centre
vont s'abstenir retenu le voir voter
voter sachant que les sondages sont
tard 1997 décide de dissoudre
sont très intéressés entendre sa
monsieur macron s'était donné un rôle
éoliennes en mer et il veut mettre aussi
politique
le plaisir j'ai pour vous les résultats
l'avenir mais en rassemblant et en
faire élire le maximum de gens autour de
étonné de son côté combatif et
alain petit réservoir de voix pour
je pense que ça ne s'est pas passé de la
grandiose un la pyramide du louvre
s'avère compliquée la ligne entre ça et
du débat 57,5 contre 42,5 et puis vous
parlé de vote utile au premier tour
mathieu on revient sur l'importance de
sa campagne et pour ce qui est du voile
c'est fait pour ça c'est pour ça qu'on a
en particulier mais un peu partout d'un
dans un grand bureau de scrutin à paris
victoire on peut lui laisser la chance
peut-être effectivement qui pourrait
sont en train de digérer est ce qu'ils
60 alors certains groupes d'électeurs
parlait peut-être plus plus tôt dans la
abstenu ou encore on a voté blanc la
darveau prend le relais avec d'autres
oui mais c'est un sujet qui est majeur
fait rare qu'on se fait réélire par le
marseille où mélenchon et populaires
une victoire quand même éclatante dans
eux d'où le fait que maintenant emmanuel
dollars ce qui donc fait dire à emmanuel
objectif le nu disco moi je n'ai entendu
veut faire ça est ce qu'il veut en faire
beaucoup reprochent on a été bons on
devaient donner de certains signes qui
tout cas après le premier tour lui il
semaine y beaucoup de sondages qui ont
l'extrême droite qui a gagné du terrain
irrationnelle qu'il peut qu'il peut
sécurité quand vous conduisez et bien
votes blancs il y avait eu un record en
en danse et outre-mer où les inégalités
c'est un risque en tout cas pour lui
non seulement pour l'europe et pour le
proposé les candidats est ce que l'on
partis chez zemmour et faire une sorte
l'émission je retrouve sur le terrain à
reconnaît plus
faire la coalition dé droite de la
sont favorables emmanuel macron je vous
au delà même un petit peu mais quand
leurs efforts pour
un hasard vous savez qu'il est quand
c'est à dire un certain nombre de gens
c'est long alors on a les résultats
du premier tour au canada donc la
assez précis ici et qu' ils donnent tous
autant
alors qu'en 2017 il avait dit allonger
campagne lorsqu'à émerger eric zemmour
bulbe réussite et voici quelqu'un qui a
pour tenter de parler à cet électorat en
élargissant ce qui par facile bon mais
cette majorité présidentielle pour
tout ça c'est à dire ce système tout ça
l'universel serait le premier pays au
aussi qui ne s'est pas sentie
réactions à très bientôt
pour les logements sociaux par exemple
macron leur promet un premier ministre
moria alors les premiers chiffres que
l'assemblée nationale pour son objectif
chapelle ardente dimanche prochain et
personne ne s'est vu les résultats des
accaparement des pouvoirs par
pour marine le pen en tout cas dans a
neuvième symphonie bon c'était quand
mélenchon 1er juillet ce n'est pas fait
fait au québec raphaël bouvier au clair
doivent être apportées à une partie de
la priorité de son mandat de cinq ans ça
été faits et puis ça varier de 5 ans 5
présenté comme la revanche de celui de
ce qui s'en vient les législatives avec
vous allez être mis à l'amendé
a été battu donc ces deux pays de
oui d'ailleurs ça changeait évidemment
avoir plus de députés qu'en 2017 qui
macron qu'elle n'est pas crédible quand
de fédération dé droite nationale et
en place un système de location
quand même qu'ils voulaient important de
même manière donc on va on va sans doute
paris sylvain desjardins qui sera dans
monde entier bah ça c'est clair que
rapproché les législatives des
droit en allant d'abord cherché à gauche
qui étaient à gauche ou à droite
qui revient aussi sur le terrain parce
droite nationale il a bien cité dans
peuple français j'imagine que vous êtes
même élu largement par les retraités qui
elie pas sûr qu'elle franchisse la
sauf si pendant ces 50 jours il se passe
en dix ans et reste chez toi moi je vais
les critères des élections françaises il
susciter c'est à dire oui il a eu des
essentiellement des petits endroits là
quelques-uns plus que jamais je
convaincre les électeurs notamment de
conclu de consultation organisée par les
sociales sont terribles au deuxième tour
marine le pen croyez qu'il ya eu des
ça vaudrait pour les processus de
interpellée représentée par les deux
lorsqu'elle avait été interpellée
de se rattraper il ya cinq ans devant
2010 est de votre blank 4 millions je
qui fera de cette question là un enjeu
l'âge de départ à la retraite ce sont
porter le programme d' emmanuel macron
évite ablement
monde à interdire les signes religieux
tout au cours de ces années où lui s'est
dit c'est un référendum sur l'europe
même au delà de ce que les derniers
présidentielles pour donner une majorité
non plus parce qu'on l'a beaucoup dit
nous avons ce qu' a priori nous mais et
qu'on en rencontre beaucoup on en a
elle parle de la russie parce qu'elle
compilation de tous les consulats
la population ce qu'il déteste
lundi prochain au centre bell derrière
mensuelle de voitures électriques à
à paris tout au long de cette émission
échangeant parfois dans de très longs
va mais pour le reste il y avait quand
garder un lien avec jeux poutine
ça c'est en 2017 et puis à droite en
ravi
qui le nouveau président le nouveau
emmanuel macron gagnant est ce que le
justement on le voit pendant qu'on le
au fil de la campagne et souvenez-vous
vous avez vu ces images là par une femme
les les jaunes qui repartent ou une
serait déjà une très bonne performance
c'était de renforcer sa majorité à
le camp de maquereaux et annexe béraud
l'union européenne qui aujourd'hui ont
présidentielles
ne peut plus durer et ça effectivement
personne ne lui a demandé où il se
aussi ce message martelé par jean luc
tensions tout au long de cette campagne
l'ordre reconquête c'est-à-dire son
lui quand même donc il peut
les vieilles formules moi je sais faire
aujourd'hui à mon avis ce qui le
poursuivrai mon engagement pour la
candidats et qui n'a même pas voulu
insoumis le premier choix c'était quand
sur l'écologie l'école l'économie la
recrutement en entreprise ça vaudrait
au ministère de l'intérieur monsieur m'a
40% ça devient impossible c'est une
on va dire à 57 pour monsieur macro et
c'est à cette élection là et qui gagnent
bon mais j'ai fait mon temps au
rencontré pendant cette campagne des
prioritaire alors ce qu'il faudra
n'aiment pas la part les plus de 60 ans
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on explique
assister à quelque chose assez grandiose
petites phrases malheureuses oui il a
faut qu'il soit très humble et dire j'ai
c'est donc le pari de de jean-luc
sondages qui ont été dévoilés en fin de
petit prix du côté de marine le pen
généraux outrance au pays emmanuel
vous
bonsoir à tous les trois c'est rare et
dans l'espace public
2017 mais la revanche annoncée a tourné
voit parcourir les rues de paris vers le
jean luc mélenchon de les rejoindre et
avec nous raphaël bonjour bonsoir pour
crois un peu plus de 4 millions de
depuis le début de cette émission c'est
quand la candidature d'eric zemmour a
quelque chose de son côté s'il donne
président réélu il va on s'en doute
moments il faut le dire emmanuel macron
autrement bon bah le problème c'est que
liés à l'immigration vraiment le centre
entre le camp reconquête des hémorroïdes
président le président élu devra
pour lui après le fait que mes l'enfance
rapprochement avec la demi-heure poutine
même je le disais puisque la kippa ne
2022 donc il occupe un vaste
clan de tous ceux qui avaient appuyé
dans le camp de le pen alors sylvain
c'est marine le pen qui est très en tête
électeurs qui se disent écoutez c'est du
installé au pouvoir faudra voir qu'on va
emmanuel macron s'il est réélu ce soir
même un petit peu de contrition petit
france et les français la persévérance
l'assemblée nationale erreur grossière
contraire elle veut mener l5 entre elles
propre parti 7% des voix rassemblement
aller faire barrage à l'extrême droite
confirmé leur ancrage européen et leur
santé etc etc et c'est vrai que c'est
aussi l'effondrement et des républicains
pour les aides sociales ce qu'elle veut
effectivement
veut très bien alors monsieur legault
sont infernales de gagner haut la main
défaite qui s'apparenterait à celle de
détestaient au moins dans cinq ans je ne
surveiller si monsieur mc ren est réélu
parce que en effet je vous confirme là
chrono un petit peu plus que millions de
il disait pas plus on a une bonne marge
mélenchon pas une voix à marine le pen
le premier pays au monde c'est ça ce que
faut lui reconnaître il va à la
oui exactement vous l'avez dit donc les
même à 45% par par les militants a
quelques images très liés à la
justement des signes qu'il a entendu
macron était arrivé premier avec 36% des
personnes qui étaient allés qui
surtout une politique qui est quand même
vous
j'ai entendu qu'ils avaient cigale
qui n'aime pas la aventure et il a eu
les plus récents étaient les plus précis
cinq ans plus tard il dit finalement on
mélenchon c'est le pari d essayer de
campagne nous indique m c'était à peu
mélenchon bien sûr vont seront allés
pas parce que les socialistes et les
seraient pas concernés le chahut ne
aient déçu veut dans la portière mais
avancée mais à saluer quand même madame
au sortir de la guerre en ukraine donc
l'environnement ce n'est clairement pas
après midi dans deux mois ça me paraît
alors il ya des gens dans ce groupe là à
peu je vais changer c'est ce qu'il
erreur parce que son pari est totalement
travailler il doit avoir un gouvernement
alors en italie en allemagne il ya déjà
bonjour patrice alors vous allez vous
c'est même un exploit quand on a la
été annoncée même dans la période qui a
marine le pen avait semblé dire que bon
et du parti socialiste avaient voté
quand le camp du rassemblement national
pareil au même ce sont tous les mêmes
champ-de-mars où il va s'adresser aux
le coeur de sa proposition politique
alors que d'habitude l'extrême droite
2010 est pour l'instant et puisqu'on est
cécile propose des solutions concrètes
aussi s'est accélérée des renvois
vous l'expliquer l'importance des
sais pas mais il ya des politiques qui
rencontre des électeurs est en tout cas
vous proposez ça n'a aucun sens ce n'est
soumis un choix de vote blanc ou
national celui qui était quand même au
poursuivre sur cette lancée là demain
va faire un peu plus et il a quand même
et zemmour elle est la plus forte mais
dansant dans ce résultat là et je
un vaste centre
près dans ces eaux là mais il les a
révolution il ya même les riches et les
pas facile monsieur mitterrand n'en
d'abord jette en direct du rassemblement
seraient pas concernés donc une
quelque chose du premier tour et
quand même
ancrage pour une démocratie une
une politique qu'on va mettre vraiment
républicains se sont effondrés aux
plus on aura de la légitimité pour
d'ici qu'on aura le résultat des ces
de la baie avec nous dans un taxi à
précédé y montait dans les sondages au
dernier où clairement monsieur mc ren a
dans ces anti il y à des individus de
pourquoi j'irai voter il ya un
qui vient de féliciter monsieur macron
élu ce fameux donc 3e tour après les
son sujet de prédilection elle dit tout
voter dans une proportion équivalente
perdu il devient il reste président
on est à 57 5 donc ça dit quand même
peuvent changer malgré tout ouïe et qui
pas trop hein parce que les mots qui
qui voulait s'adresser aussi puis
discrimination entre les religions qui
est-ce que ça a eu un effet est-ce que
court
sur une télé canadienne dont on parlait
sauf que cette sortie de guerre en
dépassés et quand même par contre plus
législatives avec qu'il gouvernera
majorité au parlement parce que
emmanuel macron pour ce coup pour dire
fallait je suis touchée je vais changer